[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this I can't
believe it this is Jason Alexander the
Great Jason Alexander and Alexander the
Great Well there it was in front of us
the whole time
so thrilled that I got to sit down with
this remarkable human being I'm so glad
you guys are here to check it out as I
always say let's get to it as quickly as
possible just a couple quick plugs
including my new tour here's the art
there's the art Pete Holmes the where
were we tour we're going to be launching
this art soon I'm going to be in Toronto
Atlantic City New Jersey Boston Chicago
San Francisco Portland Seattle Atlanta
Charlotte and Washington DC that's just
the beginning uh hopefully by the time
this is live tickets will be at
petehomes.com I'm pretty sure they will
be so go to petehomes.com for tickets or
if you're in the Los Angeles area go to
largo-la.com I do a monthly show at
Largo always the highlight of my month
please come to that so so so so fun
Dimitri Martin did it recently Amy
Schumer Rory Scoville John Mulaney Judd
Apatow incredible musical guests as well
so hope you can make that the next one
is September eighth but if you're in any
of those cities Toronto Atlantic City
Boston Chicago San Francisco Portland
Seattle Atlanta Charlotte or Washington
DC hope to see you for the where were we
tour Shaboom I'm holding it up for the
YouTube for the YouTube people for the
audio people you can see it on my
Instagram or just live in mystery
wondering what the what the tour art
looks like but go to petehomes.com for
tickets and guys as you know uh the show
is supported by the Pete's picks if you
like this show we don't have a patreon
but if you want to support try a Pete's
pick like living Libations living
Libations is an incredible skin hair
teeth everything body uh skin care
natural organic beautiful healthy and
real I realized years ago I was very
mindful about what I was putting in my
body but I wasn't being very careful
about what I was putting on my body it's
buying shaving creams and face wash that
I thought were fancy because they had
like French names or they maybe they
were expensive but of course these
companies Don't Care About Us these
these products are filled with toxicity
levels that were never intended for
human consumption what you put on your
skin gets into your body and can lead to
all sorts of problems so obviously I
want to eat food where I recognize the
ingredients but I also want my skin care
to be the same I want my toothpaste to
be the same I want my face wash to be
the same so we are top to Tails this
whole house is a living Libations
household and I reached out to them and
I'm so glad that we're working together
but we absolutely love them first and
foremost every morning before Leela Goes
to School Preschool we are slathering
her in sunscreen so many sunscreens out
there you go on Amazon or whatever claim
to be natural but they're just not if
you want a real legit long-lasting great
acting sunblock zinc based sunblock we
get their love the sun sunscreen stream
it is incredible at Living Libations I
also I just happen to have just shaved
my shaving rituals their gendrix
exfoliating scrub then I use their Zen
shave lotion and aft a shaving lotion
that is so natural and moisturizing you
can actually use a dab of it as your
aftershave try doing that with some
Anonymous blue green goo you get from a
pressurized can at night I use their
best skin ever moisturizer smells great
feels great keeps your skin looking
great both Val and I use that before
your bed but this is a great way to
support the show if you like the show
they have small products they have big
big products you can do a complete
medicine cabinet overhaul or you can
just try something small it makes a
difference it supports the show and it's
good for your body and your needs I'm
going to talk about your needs it's good
for your needs whatever you need a face
body eyes teeth even baby care Living
Libations has a premium natural and
wonderful product to replace the random
chemical nightmare use get at 7-Eleven
so go to livinglibations.com and use
promo code weird Botanicals that's
capital W and capital B weird Botanicals
one word
that'll get you 15 off do your body a
favor and do the show a favor it means a
lot to have your support
livinglibations.com promo code weird
Botanicals check it out also you might
notice this what is this this is my
Apollo neuro this is probably the
product that I tell people about in my
everyday life more than any other uh up
there with certainly magic mine these
are the ones that are the ABCs of my
life and Apollo has absolutely changed
my life has changed Valerie's life what
is it it is a wearable piece of tech
that uses subtle vibrations that give
your body the sensation of being held
it's like a wearable hug for your
nervous system that uses touch therapy
to help you feel safe and in control I
wear mine on the wrist Val wears hers on
her ankle I can actually feel it maybe
you can hear it vibrating maybe you
can't it's very subtle Val wears it on
their on her ankle you can also clip it
to your belt is a new thing they have
and it uses these soothing vibrations to
train your nervous system to recover and
rebalance after stress it's like finding
the uh the fuse box to your nervous
system they have an energy and wake up
setting that you really feel that gets
your heart pumping perfect if you're
trying to get motivated or to work out
or if you're in a boring meeting you put
it on energy and wake up it's like
espresso that you're wearing but it
doesn't get you all jacked and jolty
social and open clear and focused is
what I use it on most days when I'm
doing this podcast or when I'm writing
actually helps counter some symptoms of
ADD some real exciting data coming out
for that as well I currently have it on
rebuild and recover because I just
exercised and it is using this this
technology to help my body recover and
come back to Baseline meditation and
mindfulness is incredible I always say
if it just helped you meditate more
deeply it would be worth it but it
absolutely got me deeper in my
meditation practice than anything else
deeper than I've been in years relax and
unwind is when what I put it on when I'm
watching TV at night helps me get ready
tells my body that I am getting ready to
go to sleep and sleep in renew which is
incredible because now that I'm older
sometimes I get up to go to the bathroom
in the night I get back in bed push
these two buttons it reruns the program
and lulls me back to sleep I sort of
explain it to people how like tapping on
your body and then slowing that tap down
and slowing that tap down just kind of
hypnotizes you and helps you ease and
de-stress that is a very inaccurate but
sort of parable style explanation of a
polynero I always tell people that it is
not uh woo-woo it was developed by a
neuroscientist and board certified
psychiatrist who have been studying the
impacts of chronic stress in the human
body for over for nearly 15 years and
Apollo's effects on stress sleep
cognitive performance and Recovery have
been proven in multiple clinical trials
and real world studies so this is not a
crystal you know I like that sort of
stuff I like it in you know new age year
or weird that's what the show is about
weird stuff this is not that this is
science and it absolutely has made a
huge difference in my life we've got
them for friends we've got them for
young friends really young friends that
are dealing with stress absolutely wish
I knew about it years ago has made my
life that much better and you can get 10
off and show your support of the podcast
and give it a try by going to Apollo
neuro that's
a-p-o-l-l-o-n-e-u-r-o.com slash weird
get 10 off and show your support of the
show that's apollonuro.com weird for 10
off and get into it last but not least
guys is our friends at ritual I have it
right here this is my ritual symbiotic
plus this is my Prebiotic my probiotic
and my postbiotic all in one you guys
know if you listen to the show I'm all
about that gut health I think so many
problems can be traced back to the
breeding ground of the bacteria that
makes us basically who we are that's
essentially like a second brain and so
many of us especially in America we're
not supporting our gut health and not
only does ritual make my favorite
multivitamin that I take every morning
which I love they now make synbiotic
plus let me ask you does your probiotic
contain clinically studied strains meet
one that does rituals symbiotic class
contains two of the world's most studied
strains with over 350 publications of
human clinical trials so what makes the
components so clearly what ritual
there's science-backed and research
stacked especially when stacked up
against the leading direct to Consumer
and top-selling probiotics on the market
these guys are all about transparency
and letting you know what is what it's
more than a probiotic three in one with
clinically studied prebiotics which is
what probiotics basically need
prebiotics to eat it's what helps them
survive and post-biotics to support a
balanced gut
microbiome it's single nested in a minty
capsule here I'll show it to the YouTube
Friends see it's like this you don't you
don't have to taste anything in fact
what you do taste
was great is mint it gives you like a
lovely minty aftertaste but you're
getting all this goodness in one daily
capsule for simple streamline
streamlined gut support and it is
designed to thrive that means it's a
delayed release capsule designed to
reach the colon not the stomach you
don't want these things breaking down in
your stomach you want a delayed release
so they can thrive in your colon which
is the ideal place for probiotics to
survive and grow and the best part is
you don't have to refrigerate them you
just keep them in your cupboard designed
with moisture controlled bottle
technology to protect the probiotic
strains so symbiotic plus and ritual are
here to celebrate not hide your insides
there's no more shame in your gut game
that's why ritual is offering weirdos 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com weird to start ritual or add
symbiotic plus to your subscription
today that's ritual.com weird for 10 off
for the first three months and show your
support of the show and show your
support of your body and your microbiome
and your second brain your gut brain get
into it all right everybody enjoy I
can't I still thank you to Michael
Rosenbaum we talk about him in the
episode he gave me the connection to
Jason so glad it happened thank you to
Michael guys get into it
I bought and feel free to Get Cozy
you're a theater man
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my God I said when you came in no
short jokes I won't have it you're the
guest of honor come on but I mean that's
a good place to start so you're okay
getting on this couch and being comfy a
lot of people won't do that really
they resist
how do you how do you know the way to
navigate how do you resist just get on
it liquid death not in the water
what the hell is that you just give it a
little turn liquid Death Mountain Water
I really thought this was going to be
like you know some Uber Red Bull product
it does look like an energy drink that
gives you a third of an erection but it
doesn't it doesn't get you all the way
by the way that's that's all we need
that's well I've been working with that
for at least 15 years
you mean uh one third Alexander yeah
but that's all you need 33 is he a
sponsor is this a sport this is a
sponsor they're going to be thrilled let
me do that they're going to be open
favor them
that's right I do commercials but I mean
right it's a it's a fact of life the
liquid that's keeping the lights on but
I really have a question first of all
what a thrill stop it what a thrill
again finish your thought but it's uh I
know by the way I have stolen that line
finish your thought I think it's I think
it was Jerry Seinfeld I think that's the
first time I heard it and I don't know
if he appropriated from somebody but
it's such a great somebody would say
something nice about him and he'd go
please it's too much stop you're
embarrassed finish your thought
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure he was
Jerry very good I uh I wouldn't Norm I
wasn't planning on bringing this up
let's say that but when I met Jerry it
was like an episode of Seinfeld in that
or curb you know very similar shows but
like I he complimented something I had
done and I went like this I went
I went right like that the old squeezy
eye doll yes but I mean I really did
that yeah I literally went like and I'm
standing closer than we are like we're
in a crowded little party thing and I go
and I could tell like the Opera hands of
the pilot I blew it like I like I wasn't
really worried that I blew it but I was
like I've gone too big too big right
same when I met Larry David I said big
fam and he looked at me like I swear to
God his face if the subtitles were on
don't say big fan wow that's that's what
it that's what it was really and then
flanny who runs Largo I don't know if
you've ever been to Largo it's a theater
we'll get you there great shows yeah
awesome that's where Larry was and for
anyone don't say big fan don't say big
really but he they he was sort of
breaking my balls but I I didn't think
it was since I would have thought that
that Larry it would have been okay
trying to think what I mean well let me
ask you I haven't written the book on
Larry David but I I can't imagine that
he would find that to be you haven't
voted inappropriate professionally and
yeah yeah yeah I I carry a piece of him
around at all times but your blood type
is your blood type but also a little bit
okay yeah right take whatever Larry's
yeah which I think is like raw cashes
and spring water I'm not sure whatever's
keeping that man alive yeah it's it's
phenomenal he's going for it he is
there's he looks now the way he looked
30 years ago and I don't know that's
good better and different but I mean it
may have been he looked a little older
than he should have back then or he
looks fantastic now but he yeah you know
he's certainly successful and I as close
to happy as Larry's gonna get so I think
he's he feels uh he feels uh vibrant and
alive and I always projected onto it
that he was uh by the way I have to do
this because this looks like we're gonna
go fly fishing later what what is
happening
okay
[Laughter]
fruits don't have to die for them to be
I don't think so no no no no no no
no no
no that's all it's optional it's
optional oh no you don't
know no birthday these feathers I
promise you
yeah this is a Woodsman yeah
we're taking from two men of the woods
troop five near Maple New Jersey Boy
Scouts here I always thought it was that
when some people when their number comes
in in a big way then they go like well I
have one of the I I could I have the
potential to live one of the greatest
lives of all time so I should stop
eating melted cheese constantly some
people go the other way and they're like
I'm gonna email them I'm the king right
yeah you can't tell me what's going to
stop me now right but there are other
examples other than Larry David I'm
trying to think but none come to mind
when they're really like like I just saw
Mark Maron in Montreal yeah and he's
going Larry David he's well I don't know
what he's doing but he looks vegan let's
say that yeah Larry I don't think Larry
again I'm not I know I should be the
Aficionado on Larry David but I don't
think Larry changed it up in a big way
when well that's successful I I you know
he doesn't live in in Manhattan Plaza
Apartment Complex anymore in New York
but he's got some property but I don't
you know it's it's the people I think he
hangs with have changed yeah but I don't
think his his day-to-day tastes about
stuff he was always kind of a healthy
guy
well you know we used to do a thing so
images of pizzas the only time we all
kind of hung out really yeah was after a
taping we'd go to the Jerry's Deli uh
that used to be there on Ventura
Boulevard and uh and we'd sort of do a
debrief about the show the writers and
the core cast would go and so I'm trying
to think back there was there was a game
that that Jerry and I and I remember
maybe Larry Charles or some of the
writers used to play about we would
order as if you were upping the ante at
a poker game
you know that may you may get
indigestion but this order will kill me
and I remember Larry kind of
participating in that so I guess he was
a bit of a of a Cavalier eater but well
I have to think
okay so we're only going to talk about
you this just happened to come up I
remember I was obsessed with Seinfeld
when I was young because I grew up
religious and he was clean so I was very
interested in him as a comedian and then
I would read like books and stuff about
him and then it would say something like
at rap everyone would smoke cigars and I
was like Jerry like I had this weird
yeah almost Latter-Day Saint protection
of him whereas like
[Music]
exactly but that is true that was a um
they used to go back so Jerry and Larry
shared I was not a cigar smoker much to
my father's Chagrin because my father on
his deathbed when he hadn't eaten for a
month or had you know water to drink for
a week said dad can I get you anything
kill for a cigar uh is that true oh yeah
did you give him one he was in a room
with oxygen I mean
I wanted to I actually I I said come on
get him a piece is it correct yeah it
was going to be fun but
um yeah the guys used to go I think uh
Jerry and Larry always shared an office
and I think they would go back and
they'd pop open the the humidor okay but
I know yeah Jerry's a cigar smoker yeah
well that that was so the first thing we
said you came in the house and it and
we're moving out I'm like we're moving
to Ohio and we were talking about my
sitcom the line being clear yeah I do
you remember where your dressing room
was at Radford because yeah well I had
two because we were on two different
stages at Radford we started in the back
on stage
we were in 19. and then we moved to the
front on stage nine right up front so
right up front
um if you if you came out the big garage
door and you turned to the right and
there was a staircase up to the second
floor and if you went up to the second
floor came around and went Three Doors
Down that was my dressing room okay well
I don't think we're in the same I'm
right above a Lanes I don't know if they
changed it to a lens here I don't know I
you know that lot
has completely changed since we were
there it's doubled in size all that
other stuff yeah that was none of that
was there we didn't have they built a
little tiny New York Street for us
because we were we had gotten to the
point where we kind of were outside a
lot and we needed a real New York Street
so we were gonna I think the rumor was
we were going to go over to Paramount
because they had that great big one and
uh and Robertson wait put up something
and they did they built like a two two
block I wish I could think of it which
is why we never left those two blocks if
you notice nine years we're on those two
blocks nothing else in New York exists
fantastic well this this look we we went
right I always pledge I'm like we're
gonna do the interview where we don't
cover the things that you always get
asked sure but let's let's begin again
even though all right Delight for me
sure here's my first my first real
question for you my most genuine
curiosity how is it being Jason
Alexander here's a little preface when I
opened the door for you you just made me
happy I was just happy to see you oh
that's so sweet well you know and right
back at you I appreciate that is that
why is that do I um
[Laughter]
how is it you know
um it's generally lovely I I do not live
a life that I anticipated in any way
although
I knew at 12 years old that I wanted to
be an actor but I I thought of a very
different kind of career I was just
trying I grew up in New Jersey and I
fell in love with the theater so I was
just trying to get across the river I
just wanted to be a stage actor in New
York and that's what I was doing in the
80s and I was
blissfully happy but it wasn't it's not
this it's not celebrity it's not
um uh the financial security that I've
gone
and I had no uh particular fantasies
about it about being this
so it has uh
what the part that's lovely and
wonderful
um
my mom was a nurse and a nurse educator
all their life and she truly like all
Jewish Mothers wanted me to potentially
go into medicine
um
primarily because she thought that a
good a good life is a life of service
being in service to other people sorry
we have to go to a commercial break
liquid death
just when I am confronted with that
level of beauty and nobility yeah it is
sort of humbling yeah my mom really did
believe in that yeah and and
it has it certainly used to strike me
that being an actor is the
quintessential opposite of that I do
this because I have a flare for it it
brings me joy and eventually I was able
to make a career out of it but I always
thought of it as a very very sort of
selfish profession you know God forbid
we get to the end of the show and people
don't clap you're going [__] you you
know yeah sure so
what I have learned and maybe it's the
the body of the career but it's
certainly Seinfeld
and I've told these stories before but
but I'll I'll walk through one or two of
them quickly I've been interrupted by
the best that's right
I probably hear from people at least
once every other week but several times
a month still
specifically about Seinfeld where they
will say to me either in letter or in
person I was going through really hard
stuff yes I lost a parent I lost a child
I was fighting cancer I was serving
overseas I was something horrible was
happening to me there was no joy in my
life I would put your show on
and the laughter would come back and
honestly you guys saved my life yeah and
you hear that and you go
well maybe I stumbled into a life of
service I was gonna walk you there
anyway yeah look I I grew up in the
church and something that blew my mind I
believe it was Rob Bell said this to me
he was like service doesn't mean you
hate it it doesn't have to be right
we thought uh Jim Gaffigan has a great
joke I think it's a great joke where he
goes uh you want to do something good
and you're like I want to feed the
Homeless and they're like great meet us
at 6 a.m in the park and he's like [__]
the homeless this is when Jim was dirty
right [__] the homeless and I was like
that's what I thought service was if you
it's like people that say if you're
giving uh money and it doesn't hurt it
doesn't count right like what is this
alcoholic it really is an alcoholic
drunk dad upstairs in the Attic who's
gonna beat us who we're never good
enough right it's this like perverted
image I think service when it is in line
with what you love doing anyway that's
that's a beautiful symbiotic well and
now you know over the last
15 years or so I I started teaching
about 20 years teaching acting and I've
been developing you know what do I do
how do I do it how can I convey it what
but
in my teaching and in my directing
because that's mostly what I've been
doing I've learned it's all about don't
serve yourself serve your partner serve
your partner that's a great choice for
you that's really funny that's a great
moment for you what does it do for the
guy standing next to you because he's
just standing there with egg now
yes you've got to make a great choice
but you got to make a great choice that
tees him up so he can give you something
back and and it's become a big big theme
in in my awareness anyway
please speaking of things you've told
before but Michael Rosenbaum who put us
in touch I listened to you on his
podcast and I there was only one thing
that I was like we have to talk about
that so forgive
I want to talk about teaching I want to
talk about all of those things and
directing but tell the story about when
you were having panic attacks on stage
at in the theater oh and Broadway would
you mind because it ties into what you
just said yeah the way I got out of it
yeah yeah it tears us apart no matter
what we're doing so it was my uh yeah
third Broadway show uh it was a Neil
Simon play it was in that Brighton Beach
Memoirs Trilogy it was called Broadway
band I was in the original cast and I
knew it was an important piece for me
because I wasn't it was the first time I
wasn't singing and dancing on Broadway I
was being an actor and it was Neil Simon
it was a great role and
um
in the the set of that thing was a
two-story house as if you cut a house in
half and you were looking inside and the
second I have a fear of heights so it
always kind of freaked me out a little
bit anyway when I was on the second
story of the house but one night there's
a scene where Linda Lavin and the
gentleman playing her husband Phil
Sterling have this intense scene but I
am asleep on stage in my bed in full
view of the audience yeah and you don't
forget the bed was awesome yes I've only
felt like everything
um and you know you don't want to be a
distraction so you you lay there you
don't move you don't can I interject and
say when I heard you tell this story on
Mike's podcast I was like oh he's going
to talk about the time he fell asleep oh
no because of course like you're like
really get into it you're supposed to be
sleeping and you fall asleep yeah no so
and in the middle of lying up there a
thing that had never happened to me
before I got this panic panic cold
sweats my body started to shake and
every part of my being was going you got
to get off you've got to get off get off
the stage get off the stage get off the
day and I just you know I'm grabbing the
frame of the bed and just holding on
because I have to wait out this scene
and then I have to finish the ACT it's
my scene can I ask this isn't yes this
isn't just a
it's not like an actor's nightmare
you're not like I don't know my lines
I'm afraid of my of the audience it's
not that it was irrational yeah totally
irrational I think
this is the only explanation I have is
because I was
doing a lot of doing CP at the time
sure I was ingesting yes I had started
something before that
um
I think it's because I was completely
inactive and and it had gotten to a
point in the Run we had been doing it
for two months three months where I
wasn't concerned about how to keep the
performance alive I kind of had it in my
bones at that point yeah I think I went
totally out of my head and I went
hey man
you're in a Neil Simon play on a
Broadway stage
right and it just kind of went oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God yeah and I
freaked yes and it was the only place in
the show where my character is
completely inactive the rest of the time
I'm spewing lines or I'm doing something
and in that pocket just it gave me time
to freak out so it was so
startling that all I did the next day
was worry is that going to happen again
and of course it did
worse and then worse and then were and I
it was consuming my life because you're
all day long you're going I don't know
what's going on I don't know how to get
rid of it I you know this is what my
wife and I say about anxiety is it's
like Mercury it wants somewhere to pool
yeah like you have anxiety and then it
was sometimes when I'm falling asleep at
night I feel my anxiety I manage my
anxiety but I still have it I feel it
flipping through stations going like is
this enough to keep you up bet is this
enough to keep you up and I I get
curious about it and I go do you like
this and it's like yeah
like I don't know like the
commander-in-chief doesn't like it but
anxiety itself is really yeah it feels
just like one word it feeds on it and
when it finds something like oh [__]
there's the anxiety of your dream not
coming true and it goes well guess what
yeah fliparoo there's the anxiety of
your dream coming true and you're like
you son of a [__] I thought this would
put you in the ground you turn into JFK
I don't know why and now
you're now it found a place to pool and
you're worried about worrying consuming
my life and now you can't even and now
so now I'm playing mind games in it I'm
I'm you know I'm I'm lying there on that
bed freaking out and going okay what I
thought was going to happen is I thought
I was going to pass out
and and like you know undoubtedly soil
myself as I go you know yeah so it was
going to be some humiliating horrible
and I kept going go ahead okay [__]
pass out go ahead ruin your life ruin
your career you know and that's what
that's the Mind Games I play and I was
so
shaken and humiliated that this was
happening that I wasn't telling much of
anybody I told my wife yeah but I didn't
know who else to talk to I talked to a
therapist who said you know what take a
baby antihistamine before you go on or
something like oh something from the bed
so you know yeah right so I was you know
I was playing with that but that was
asking an old man take a bite of a
nectarine and the syphilis terrine
Robitussin
a little Robitussin will take you out
anyway it had gone on for a month over a
month and so eight hours a week every
show and now I'm telling the cats and I
really and now I'm starting to say to
myself I think
I'm gonna have to not be an actor I mean
I can't live like this this is this is
gonna
so my acting Guru was a guy named Larry
Moss who's still one of the greatest
teachers of acting he's still in New
York and and he's became a dear friend
and
and I finally go I'll talk to Larry
because Larry will have something
profound to say and you know
so I go to Larry and I said Larry it's a
crow I'm having these anxiety attacks I
think I'm gonna pass out cold sweats and
I've tried this I've tried that I don't
know what to do I'm so embarrassed I'm
so humiliated by it and I'm worried it's
going to derail my career and you know I
pour my heart out
thinking I'm going to get some
sympathetic response and he doesn't take
a beat and he goes you're a [__]
egomaniac
and it just hit me like a brick and I
went what because it's all about you you
made it all about you you're gonna pass
out you're gonna ruin the show you're
gonna ruin the audience you're going to
ruin the thing you you you you you
nobody gives a [__] about you Jason you
know what they're there for they want to
see the story tell them the goddamn
story
wow and it was the coldest I mean it
really just rattled me how it did yes
I mean I'm like it's rattling as a
retelling
thanks for talking to me and I was
pissed I think you know
and I went on stage that night and it
didn't happen he I mean what do you
think that is and it didn't happen the
next night and it didn't happen or
something and he just went it's you're
making it all about you yeah you now yes
it was me ruining someone else's show
ruining someone else's experience but it
was all about what's going to happen to
me or what is happening to me
you know he didn't say this but it was
almost like saying why don't you lie
there and think about what's something
you can offer Jonathan Silverman you're
seeing partner in the next moment why
don't you focus on that that that's the
kind of thing he was saying without
saying it and
he meant it to be harsh and he meant it
to be brutal he meant it to be shock
therapy and it and it absolutely was I
mean that was the that was the linchpin
that's ended it and we're back to a
little bit of what your mom said service
like thinking about someone else would
you I mean that seems like that's a key
to [__] happiness just like a good life
like finding your place in the world is
considering others a little bit yeah
um you know it's
is going to sound so pat on the back but
are you crazy on you made it weird my
friend somebody once asked me because I
lost uh I don't know how many Emmy
Awards you know I was up for it yeah and
they said uh who'd you lose to let's
give them a bit I think three times I I
actually think I know because I think
the first three times it was um David
Hyde Pierce on Frazier okay and the
other three times I think was Michael
Richards wow so there you go you know
yeah and Niles
so as somebody said to me um
are you do you hate that are you bitter
about that do you do you have feelings
about it yeah and I said you know look
it would be nice it would have been a
lovely thing there's nothing wrong with
getting it but I said I didn't grow up
fantasizing about
Awards I really didn't yeah um if any of
them it was the Tony award because
that's where I thought I was gonna right
and I won the Tony award and I it was
great and I'm so proud to have it but I
also know
didn't change my life
you know it was a nice night and it's a
nice thing to see on your resume but it
did make me a better actor didn't make
me a better person it didn't make me a
better anything who's asking for the
resume right exactly well you'd be
surprised sorry Jason and Alex yeah
Alexander is he the one that married
Britney Spears
um my brother who's a Super Fan he said
this is a perfect impression my brother
goes ask him if he ever gets confused
for the guy who married Britney you bet
all the time really oh sure yeah I was
like I don't think that happened yeah no
it's uh and it does I mean not on the
street people don't come up and go you
married Britney Spears but in in print
they'll often go wow the guy from
sorryville
um crazy
but anyway you know so uh you've lost
when I didn't so they said do you do you
hate not getting those Awards and I said
you know
the award honestly
was the job yeah the people who I worked
with the material I got to do
the the the
good word of my colleagues other
opportunities those are the awards yeah
the statue
I'll give you every statue in the world
you give me all that other stuff that's
right I'll be happy to try it so
um and all those things are again
they're they are about the community
um I think the reason I like theater so
much is that you spend so much time
communally working on one thing can I
just enthusiastically agree yeah because
I just did a multi-cam I've never done
theater other than like you know college
and whatnot but like we were 300 people
on a stage pointed in the same direction
and there's something about these pack
animals that we are that love going
showing up and everyone agrees this is
what we're doing and if it's good
imagine if what you're doing is good
and you're all doing it together and
you're having fun while you're doing it
that's like what we were designed to do
absolutely and it's about the number uh
I'm reading the book tribe it's taking
me forever even though it's a small book
uh and the book selfie there's all these
books that are talking about us as
primates and what we're what we need and
it's always striking to me how how
closely it resembles summer camp
theater
uh all that sort of stuff yeah like like
we want to band together like Avatar I
always say like Avatar yeah we want to
be in a tribe hunting feeding each other
taking care of each other challenging
each other challenging each other
exactly not running from each other not
accusing each other shooting arrows from
a distance together together so you got
to feel that and and very much enjoyed
it yeah
the the service thing I'm gonna pop my
liquid death do it put the mic right up
very good oh look at that very and no
Sizzle you think there's going to be a
Sizzle but it's just 16.9 ounces of gin
well it's got a fine
a fine bouquet you know I'm actually now
I'm worried about spilling I'm gonna put
it over here Jay take a look at this
couch but oh that's true that's true God
knows what bodily fluids are on this
thing with them I mean swimming
uh Jimmy Carr just did this podcast and
he told me about David Lee Roth uh do
you know this David Lee Roth had a
mansion you know am I getting this right
David Van Halen is that Van Halen yeah
and he uh he called his Mansion a tomb
with a view right so we're coming back
to you teaching and and service and and
and finding ways to be in a pack pointed
in the same direction now in this point
he he trained to be an EMT so he could
be of service like your mother so I'm
wondering if that's what teaching is for
you I have to imagine it's a similar
sort of
it is absolutely a service I I would be
lying if I didn't tell you it's one of
the most selfish things I've ever done
because the joy
there there's a certain there's many
joys but the two big ones are
that feeling you get when you're in
class and the teacher asks you a
question then you know the answer yeah
that happens all the time
because I go people come up and they
have a problem and I go
I have an answer not the answer I have
an answer or it may it may help you so
there's that Joy of going oh my god look
I studied for the test and I actually
learned something so there's that yes
but there's also that moment and it's
it's thrilling and I guess this is part
of you know
um being a dad
there's a joy when your kid
a does something great and learns a
thing and you go
and then they learn something you didn't
know or you can't do and that's what
happens with students is they are often
working on a piece of material that that
I go I can help you
I couldn't do it yeah but I can stand
out here and help you and then they do
this thing and they do they they
accomplish something that you go I would
not have made that choice and it's a
great choice or I I couldn't have done
that moment and they did that moment and
you get it's it's
ah well [__] uh I stand resolutely on
the shoulders of many many many Giants
that came before me to help somebody up
under your shoulder that's a cool cool
feeling yeah to go great yes go pack go
go leave me in the dust um that's fine
and
you know I just don't want to be too
obvious but it's like but I do think
people are interested in the in the idea
that you don't need it what I'm
realizing is like so much joy is hidden
in things that you don't need to do like
people think that once your train comes
in you've got enough grain for many
Winters that you should just sit around
but that's a very good Hepburn by the
way you've got enough grain from anyone
does but
tell me what gives I mean obviously
that's one of it like how are you
filling your life with meaning teaching
is part of it but it's not just sitting
around and going like I could get a jet
ski right it's like that runs out right
no because that's not of service that's
that's fun and you want to take those
breaks you and I know but tell the
people because I think there's a lot of
people going like if I was Jason
Alexander oh I'd kick it back and I
would just yeah or I'd burn a bag of
money in front of my foes or whatever it
is but like first of all I've never lost
you know listen I grew up solidly a kid
of working class parents
um
you know we were fine but I I didn't
realize how close to not fine we were on
any given day I mean my dad by the time
I was born my father was a widower sorry
that's a good title close to not funny
and it's just a picture against my life
story close to not find Jason Alexander
my dad was a widower his wife uh his
first wife took several years to die of
a horrible disease it bankrupted him and
then he had two teenage kids from that
marriage my sister
was always a sickly kid always had you
know so my dad was so in debt by the
time he married my mother and then I was
born my mother was 39 years old when I
was born never been married never had a
kid 40 year old women in 1958 did not
get pregnant my mom was around that age
in the 70s and she's like it's a miracle
and they were giving her blood that
could have been contaminated all of this
stuff went wrong right I should be nicer
to my mom
we have it on camera me realizing I
should be nicer to Irina mental no no to
me no to me but she's like yeah that
wasn't happening right but and I come
along my father's 51 years old and he
goes I'll never stop working I have to
work now till the day I mean it was I
was you know yeah why did I start
telling you that so working class
working class kids because we're talking
about how money isn't everything yeah
and
and as an actor you never know when your
next job is coming so even though I
always made a nice living I started
working on professionally I was 14. I
came out of college prematurely and I
never did anything but act again I was I
was always making a good living in my
profession because you got you had so
many commercials and I was doing
unspotted by seven right early on let me
tell you a story yes please well
um
but I never bought anything I couldn't
just pay for
yeah nothing if I bought a I bought a
motorcycle in New York it's ten thousand
dollars ten thousand dollars I mean if I
couldn't buy it because I wasn't sure
there was going to be any more money
coming in yes
I kind of still feel right so you know
we go yeah we have we have money but I
also
I'm not I spend money I mean we we but
we
I know you agree on one house
I own my house and I own my
mother-in-law's house that's our
property do you ever have nerd to burn
it down here like this oh it's beyond
threats I've burned sections of the
house
that [__] is late with rent whoo
I mean we don't have we have I drive a
Prius uh we don't collect art my wife's
a painter we don't collect our we put my
wife's work out yeah she doesn't like
jewelry she doesn't so we don't we don't
spend on luxury things where we have
spent our money is on our kids education
and that includes taking them to places
around the world so they can see other
people in other worlds you know uh and
taking friends with us buying time with
people that we care about and going
let's go have an adventure yeah you know
that you that might be hard for you but
isn't hard for us so let's go do that
look just a little bit of love coming
your way it just does me so I thought
you were gonna say can you be my friend
yes you can be my friend
oh yeah I'd love to go on an adventure
no I was just gonna say it just it just
fills my heart up to hear you say this
instead of being like buddy I don't want
to say but I I've I've just had people
on this couch that
hadn't figured it out yet we're waiting
for it you're here in 20 years of
therapy here yeah you know I mean it
took you a while to figure that out yeah
please where else did you look before
you found this balance oh please you
know I I put way too much emphasis on
work yeah
um what people thought of you
oh wow or just whether or not
yeah what you know
how am I seeing do I have power do I
have control do I have uh you know I
know better uh if we did it my way you
know it's all that stuff the ego the ego
has to learn I had you know I I didn't
realize that I had crap as a kid I
thought I was a pretty happy kid but I
turns out I was a pretty intimidated shy
overwhelmed disproportionately scared
kid who overcompensated with all kinds
of awful silly behaviors and
and it carried in and you know until I
was in my 20s and 30s until I finally
went you know I'm a father and I'm
having these weird feelings and ideas
and things that are the the things you
were talking about the the Rolodex of
things you're up at night going yeah you
want to think about that for a while you
want to think about that for a while
yeah and you know finally went into
therapy and started to work on what were
those things I I'm not this isn't
clickbait you have full control over
this I mean I'm curious you know the
easy ones are things where
I will have said things in interviews
that I thought I was just being
entertaining
and I was never a comic I didn't even go
into acting thinking I was going to be a
comedic actor and suddenly that's the
world I'm in and trying to be funny
and I don't I don't I guess I now I kind
of go well I guess I have a sense of
humor but I never thought of myself as a
funny guy and so in emulating
comedy and trying to be interesting and
trying to be entertaining and trying to
be amusing I would say things that you
know weren't kind and weren't right and
and and uh you know um you see that all
the time by the way and augmenting
things that are partially true but then
you for entertainment you blow them up
and now they're out there as truth and
you go oh that's not quite how it
happened and you're and you're stuck
with that story and just stuff like that
and hurting people's feelings making bad
choices saying I'm gonna be something
not being it say I'm gonna do something
not doing it the thin line between
I run into it all the time I did it on
set today I'm I'm stopping myself
because I'm 43 I'm finally learning to
stop myself but there's a thin line the
the rush of going maybe a little too far
but it works and they love it and you
love it and everyone wins now you're
addicted to those moments and then
inevitably you're gonna say a little too
far A little too much
and and you just don't know how to clean
and it was all about you know trying to
be
some Avatar that I thought was
interesting and you know or worthy
Worthy is really more the the issue
because I always felt like
I shouldn't be there yeah
um you know people should one of the I
guess a lot of actors go into acting
because they love the spotlight I was
hiding in plain sight yeah I didn't love
being in my skin I didn't I wasn't fond
of myself
so I would
say things to give a different
impression or I would play a part it was
a break so yeah so I could so I'm not
that guy I'm this guy and it was all in
this sort of
very immature
um young immature attempt to find your
own value to be okay in your own skin
and I didn't start to get there until I
was late into my 40s I think I'm 62 now
so I haven't I haven't been yeah you
know anywhere close to being oh you're
okay this is a relatively new you know
thing and it it's it's a lot of
experience and a lot of
putting real time into not
egotistical time and attention into
yourself but
real time you know going to a therapist
and being honest and going that was a
terrible thing mistake finding a way to
get past it and going okay that happened
for a reason I'm here now yeah and and
now I know what what calls people to
that and one of the one of the lovely
gifts it gives is that I have younger
friends who are going through exactly
the same thing and I can say to somebody
who's going through a tough patch you
don't think much of yourself right now
you're in one of the top five percent of
people in the world you know why because
you give a [__] and you're looking at it
and it's scary and it's dark and you
don't like what you see in the mirror
and you're still looking in the mirror
and you're still working on it that
makes you better than most people not
worse wow it takes it takes guts and
character and it takes caring about
other people to keep looking in the
mirror and not seeing what you like and
go I have to work on this wow I have to
work on this so you know that is
we say all the time we didn't know that
or obviously that was just so beautiful
um we say all the time what use am I to
people not broken you know what I mean
like how that's great not even as an
Entertainer just as a human being right
like I have a daughter she's not yet at
the age where she can ask things but
like when if you were to ask me
something I would go I know I just did
it you were like oh I go over the line
or I exaggerate this and I'm like buddy
I can't tell you and especially the
comedian Persona you think we're like
hey what's up uh look at that well and
you think we go we're smoking a
cigarette with the martini I'm gonna
tell you something we go in the bathroom
and we go oh my God
yeah right sure and the most harsh ones
I know the the ones that would be like
look at this piece of [__] they're the
most sensitive I could tell stories but
I don't want to tell Tales of course of
course but like the the biggest people
that are like think they don't give a
[__] they're they're going backstage
I got three people in my head right now
just as you said right absolutely and
but I love what you said it's like
that you weren't getting into acting
because you wanted to Razzle Dazzle and
shine you know he wanted to get away I
also loved what you said because it took
me a long time to figure out I say on
this pod all the time your [__] is your
[__] meaning maybe you had a middle
class or in my case I had an upper
middle class upbringing I have my
parents as father Greg Boyle would say I
won so many lotteries I was educated I
was fed I was housed I was whatever it
might be right right zip code Lottery he
calls it but
still a good therapist will help you
uncover like it doesn't mean anyone
failed or or was wrong or bad it just
comes with driving a car tread on the
tire is going to wear off Something's
Gonna
stick yeah and you had you had to come
to terms with your [__] was your [__]
like even though you weren't yeah this
this or this some things happen and it's
listen I don't want to present a done
package I mean I still go yeah I go
every I go several times a month I've
been working with this wonderful woman
for
20 years yeah
you know and it's still you you it's I I
say this one I'm knocking on whatever
the hell this is I don't think yes so
I'm sure it's pressed away
so I I think I can
see myself before I act out
of my neuroses but that doesn't mean the
thought patterns are still there you
know and you still have to go
Is that real what I'm feeling and
thinking right now is that a leftover is
that is that a trained behavior is that
a uh it's still I still walk into a room
to this day I can't remember I'm gonna
name drop I think it was
I think it was Marty short because I was
doing the producers I can't think about
I was thinking about him when he said I
didn't dream of winning a Tony or I did
it's like you and Martin Short exactly
yes I think I I think it's when I was
working with Marty and
he must have referenced a couple of
people and I go oh yeah I don't think
that person likes me very much or not
yeah I don't think they like me and I
must have said it again and he went you
know you have a problem you know you
have a problem yeah you you really think
people don't like you and I go
that's true wow that's true yeah now
clearly it's because I wasn't very crazy
about myself so I'm projecting out and
and very possibly in projecting out like
that doing things again that I don't
like or admire and going well that's why
they're going to reinforce it of course
to prove yourself a profit you've just
nailed something I in the book selfie
they're talking about how we build
reality like it's sort of disturbing I
don't find it disturbing but it's like
there's no free will a lot of scientists
say there's no Free Will and what we're
doing is we're doing what we do and then
our brain retroactively goes I did that
because of this right we built these
stories but it's very dangerous if you
are your story literally scientifically
neurologically be very careful what
story you're telling because if you're
saying people don't like me buddy you're
in good company Val my wife points out
she's like you you'll test people you'll
go like I don't think they like me and
then you'll go like what's up dumb [__]
or whatever it is and I'm literally big
example I always give but it's true I
was like oh my God your baby's so fat
like I talked about how fat someone's
baby was to test them
to see will you love me even if I'm a
rascal or whatever it is but it's
because I'm going I'm too much of a
rascal let's just cut to it let's cut to
the abandonment now right here's now
tell me if you ever did this
so I used to go to a party when I was a
you know young teenager
and I would sort of put myself off on
the side and be obviously
kind of
Dark Cloud to see if anyone would notice
or care enough to come over
I mean yeah let's go for a ride let's
smoke cigarettes with sunglasses on at
night because that's me I would of
course I would do that in fact I wonder
if you feel this there was something
obviously it's dramatic but it almost
feels theatrical it's like I'm gonna put
on this silent show to see if I can draw
a crown and I still love it what we're
doing right now reminds me of
performance it's like I go like you ever
do this and isn't that what we're doing
with the audience it's like like one one
Costanza like my dad
I see him being sometimes at odds with
who he is because he relates to George
but then I see him see me see him
relating to George and he's like Ah
that's that's that's that's sad or
something I'm like [__] man we all
relate to that we're all and by the way
I get it he's trying to be my dad even
though he's almost 80 and I'm like I've
said to him playing blank I'm like Dad
the parenting is over let's just be guys
but he's still one and I admire it on in
a certain level that he still wants me
to think that he doesn't have neuroses
and I'm like we're all George we're
we're all Tony Soprano you know what I
mean we're all uh Don Draper these
depraved or or in need or broken people
absolutely and and would you talk a
little bit that that's the job is to
share
I'm going to plant one thought in your
head and see what what it makes you
think of you're under the lights you
you're louder than everybody you're on
stage and yet you use this opportunity
in a again as a primate an alpha
position I'm loud I'm above you I I have
the vantage point and yet I'm going to
use this vantage point to tell you about
my insecurities my vulnerabilities and
my fears that's in my opinion good art
it sucks if you get up and you'd be like
I'm the king I'm the best unless it's a
parody or something what does that make
you think
well you're absolutely right it's also
here's where my
sense of humor because I also grew up in
New Jersey and so part of my idea of
what funny is is busting people's balls
everybody in Jersey wants to be Joe
Pesci you know of course I think that's
the epitome of common yes and it with
Tomei and and you bet and and what I've
tried to learn over the years is
it's okay on me but it's not my best
card you know because it's it's not the
one that I it's not the one I feel it's
the one I've observed a lot and and I
know I can create a Persona that it sits
well on but but then I go but so I used
to do I agree so hard that's all right I
agree so I grew up in Boston it's not
Jersey no say I went to school in Boston
Boston in the 80s you bet and I was
walking around and I love Lenny Clark
I've met him a few times I would see
guys like Lenny and I was like making my
father laugh and I was like I can't do
that right I can't do that right the way
that they'd be like I don't even want to
do it fake to you I love roasts because
we all go in agreeing that we're gonna
do it but just like to the audience or
whatever it's not my cup of tea that's
rough literally made me think comedy
wasn't for me until I started being like
am I the only one when I uh pee in the
woods and I share some feel like I think
a bug is gonna swim up the pee and go in
and people start laughing and you're
like like uh you know and the more
neurotic absolutely more vulnerable
letting people in letting people in yeah
you get laughs because you tell them
like you let people well that's what
that's what George was all about here's
my here's my foibles here's my that's
what that's what Larry is so good and
Jerry they're so good
at creating a character that goes yes
I'm the lord of the idiot somebody I
mean that was that who stands as big
crying I am the lord of the idiots
that's right no one's stupider than me
no one's less valuable than me and when
I read uh sign language and I saw that
that was my first intro to you it was
just reading the material and I was like
and obviously no disrespect to him I was
like I have thoughts like this and he
says in the intro the difference between
me and you as I write it down and I was
like I can write it down I'm 15. I'm
literally doing nothing oh my God I have
nothing going on I can write down my
little thoughts so one of them just to
share was whenever I would go to the
movies when I was a kid and the lights
started to dim I would be afraid that I
was dying just for a second I'd be like
is the movie beginning or is it all
ending that sounds like I kind of turned
it into a Seinfeld bed I'm only laughing
because sometimes sometimes there's very
subtle lighting changes in restaurants
where I guess they go from late
afternoon to the evening service sure
and that's when I'm sitting there and
I'll turn the person next to me going
are the lights dimming or am I having a
stroke
maybe I'm having a crazy moment right
yeah I'm telling you one of my go-to
lights dim am I stroking am I dying and
you do it is this it is this it it's a
very specific time and it only happens
you know how many restaurants do that
while they have people sitting there but
hilarious
imagine how we would have been in Candle
times oh a breeze and we're panicked a
brave and we're Panic so I'm sorry you
were you were just saying the ball
breaking Jersey thing couldn't relate
more no and as I was really wasn't for
you I
I have had to come to
most of my therapy most of my journey of
trying to figure out how this works
is starting from a point where I'm not
exactly sure what happened I mean I can
point to certain things in my childhood
that is traumatic that is traumatic and
that's traumatic but I had a great
childhood I really did
but somehow I have to figure out how to
go from a kid who is
disproportionately frightened of
everything
including Big D death you know dying
um not good enough not interesting
enough I'm sorry that's what I mean
that's that's another five years of
therapy right there oh my god do you not
disturb on Jason it doesn't matter I've
had airplane mode do not disturb and it
rings in the theater and I want to kill
myself because I feel like Patti LuPone
is everywhere and she's gonna you know
tear my eyes tell me if this isn't a
curb or a George I was on Broadway
recently we went and saw uh Billy
Crystal's uh show Santa Mr Saturday
night I realize I have a tile you know
those tiles that help you find your keys
yeah and I'm wearing uh tight pants and
it's going what do you mean and I'm like
don't
don't move because it goes
and then my phone's gonna go
and then Billy Crystal's gonna go
is that Ike baronhole I'm just kidding
I'm gonna you can't turn it off no I
don't know from the tile but I don't
know from everything else look I don't
know from tile but yes keep going I'm so
sorry but we're uh we're we're agreeing
but it's all been about you know going
from that that scared um I I don't I I
don't want to be seen
to I want to be seen a certain way and
that's a [__] thing yeah
to to going you know what I said to my
therapist when I you know we've been
going to therapy but I turned 60 a
couple years ago and I said we should
step it up a little bit why I said well
I think this is act three I think the
curtain's going up on F3 and I don't
know that I've ever authentically be who
been who I am I'm not sure I know what
it is yeah and I I'd like to check out
going all right I figured it out I know
not a perfect person I'm not always
going to do the right thing but I know
who I truly am yes and I can sit with
that I can be in the room with that and
I can go that's okay if we can get to
that before I check out
that would be nice that's what you want
that's what you want you want to accept
yourself yeah like and it involves
changing behaviors and changing thought
patterns and you know working on
relationships and you know it's it's a
lot of if you're going to do it you
gotta you gotta put some time into it
and it's
listen it's also it's a luxury to be
able to do it I'm you know I'm not
sitting here going oh my God where's my
next meal how am I going to pay my
mortgage sure if if that's your you know
a big concern you you don't have time
for this stuff yeah you buy your house
motorcycle stuff you buy you betcha baby
but uh oh
but yeah it's been it's been a
fascinating but it's a brave and it's a
it's a noble thing to go like again it's
what you said
I'm not going to look away I say things
I don't like buddy you're saying
something that is right beneath the
surface I would say at least for me but
I I would pause it
of everybody it's right under the
surface going like am I being authentic
I do this I bet on stage I go round of
applause who here would just break out
crying if your dad looked you in the eye
and said I'm so sorry like and and I
just think it's an absurd thing to say
but it's also funny and I'm doing a show
Bill Burrs on the show and there's these
kind of like clearly Bill Burr fans in
the front they're mostly they're not
enjoying they're enjoying me but they're
waiting for yeah waiting for Bill I'm
like all right waiting for Bill and I go
what about you why are you laughing I'm
doing what you said like [__] you I
don't know but I'm like what's wrong why
didn't you laugh like where are you and
he's like I go you think you have a good
relationship with your father he goes
yeah and I go you haven't dug deep
enough that's that's what I said meaning
and my wife died they didn't laugh my
fans laughed but but there's something
about going deep like oh this is what I
said I go
do you have a good relationship with
your father this is a good question or
are you still just really good at
playing the part they assigned to you do
you relent do you take the sides at
Thanksgiving go back in time to who they
programmed you to be
and go yes papa or whatever it is that's
really an interesting you know what I
mean do you have a good relationship
with the real you
or does that not even occur to you that
that that's possible that you just go
like all right it's time to repeat in
1994. yeah right yeah absolutely these
are the hard questions but I see you
doing that this started as a compliment
for you you're doing what you said to do
which is to look in the mirror and not
look away
you try you try yeah you know it's it's
an ongoing thing you know who's really
good
um he's on my Instagram feed do you know
do you know sod Guru yes sad Guru I love
this he's a friend I'm just kidding this
guy wouldn't it be great yeah when I'm
listening you call him yeah
I didn't know you were into that uh oh
my God he somehow the algorithm
delivered him to me wow and I started
watching his reels and then I you know I
I probably catch two or three of his
little snippet things every day and I go
this guy yeah figured a lot of [__] out
yeah he's got a really
cool simple way of looking at stuff yep
I love the one I'll share this one's my
favorite one there he goes uh I'll do my
I'll do my side Guru imitation you wake
up in the morning is it yes yes or no
yes or no yes or no you wake up in the
morning and um
you immediately think oh what you didn't
do yesterday what you have to do today
but you're not looking forward to or the
mistake you made all you have to dig it
but he said you know what I do when I
wake up every day I smile
because a million people did not wake up
today a million people did not wake up
this morning you did wow you saw the
light of this day
is that not worth a smile wow you do
this every day
it'll change your life
and I heard that tape
four months ago five months ago I wake
up every morning now yeah and I go hey
I made it I got another one
it does make a difference okay I'm gonna
give you one that I think is going to
blow your mind okay very similar to side
Guru I add to that I in the morning the
first thing I try every morning the
first thing I try to say is yes thank
you like yes thank you you have to get
up I know you do this gotta get up for
press or some crazy flight dark your
wife's still asleep
[__] it man yes thank you it's it's
absurd I talk about it a lot yeah your
brain has no idea what to do it's so
ready to go into that groove of like she
gets to sleep and get back in the back
in the dark yes thank you there's a
there's another bit I do where I go
don't you kind of love it and I go
everything you know you can't find your
keys and you're like where are my
[__] keys you're like don't you kind
of love it isn't there something in you
because when you were a kid you played
like where are my keys right and when
I'm looking for my keys I go I'm a
[__] grown-up and and that's that
sort of yes thank you to all the
distress the traffic to missing a flight
it's a great life hack but this is the
one I'm going to give you yeah this is
from a monk I just I saw him on YouTube
and a little shout out to the fact that
I know social media all this uh you know
flashing stuff coming at us but there
are these little Oasis your little Oasis
just learn the plural of Oasis yeah uh
there's an oasis Beatles joke anyway
um
this guy says when you go to bed at
night I've been doing this
he goes we call it go to bed in a sea of
Merit meaning
replay all the things you did well that
day don't think about what you have to
do tomorrow don't think about what you
did wrong just go like I draw you drove
to my house to do this podcast that's a
that's a gift you gave a gift you were
present you gave wisdom freely you know
like what I'm saying is it doesn't have
to be like I saved a cat out of a tree
it can just be I was kind I was funny I
was present I I was attentive to my bad
driver in at the intersection even
though they were clearly wrong that's
right I and what's funny is it helps you
fall asleep immediately wow it's
incredible that's very good because your
brain is is trying to flip the channels
but if you bore it with what you're good
about it goes [__] this that's right and
it goes right to bed and you wake up and
you feel better you you feel better it's
absolutely changed my life you want the
one I started with today hit it because
I only heard it last night I thought it
was so brilliant Guru again I was like
no thanks who goes you will never do
anything with willpower
you want to lose weight you want to make
a change I have a habit you want to do
this you will never get anywhere with
willpower because willpower is I don't
want to do it but I will do it anyway he
said you'll never get there
you must do it with being blessed
wow so like uh four weeks ago I went off
wheat and sugar no more weight
yeah and you know it's like you know
and his whole thing is yeah if you look
at it as I'm I'm fighting that fight the
fights are tiring but if you go I am
blessed with energy I didn't have I am
blessed with them tasting things I
didn't taste I am blessed with my eyes
look awesome I am blessed with this I am
blessed with and you go oh so yeah if
I'm blessed to do it he goes it's just
it's the what's great about these people
is that they are able to make it almost
like a new program they go yeah here
here's a thought for the day yeah this
is that thing in action real real
behavioral and it's and you go oh that's
so smart and it sounds like something as
an actor a director would say to you
it's like George you're doing it sorry
Jason you're doing it I was picturing
them directly yeah I understand I didn't
think you were George
um I see you're doing it like it's a
what if you did it this way it's like a
shift same scene different intentions
absolutely I will join you I really feel
like we're vibing on a lot of the same
frequencies
and I just died what did he say right
before he died
um he said we were on the same frequency
getting a physical
that's the funniest thing to say before
you die you're like I feel like you and
I are on the exact same path dead
um
forget what it was I I'm one of those
people that had my nutritional life
Changed by a series of Netflix
documentaries and this is something you
should overhear at like Cafe Gratitude
or something of course but here by the
way for one second my writing partner my
podcast I'm going to talk about that my
podcast partner Peter Tilden I took him
to Cafe Gratitude yes he actually yells
that's where everything is named I am
grateful I am Serene he yells out I've
been waiting 15 minutes for my I am
patient
this is for no one but the Cafe
Gratitude on Larchmont is one of the
best restaurants ever and you can go
Sunday 11 A.M no problem no problem no
problem I don't know why I'm there
constantly yeah no it's one of my wife's
favorite restaurants it's I think it's
my favorite restaurant I mean
you're vegan I'm a bad vegan wish there
were more bad vegans right because it
shouldn't be a zero-sum thing right but
I'm mostly vegan yeah going to
Crossroads now you ever go to the
bathroom sure my wife loves it my wife
is
there should be more vegan yeah more
vegish yeah because it's a daunting
thing to go full I'm probably on my way
there to being vegish yeah yeah
well you talk about the the face and the
taste and all that stuff
and you know and
go down a little more I think I've been
holding off my doctor's visit for a year
and a half because he always he yells at
me he just goes what do I have to do
what do I have to do hilarious it's
always you got to knock off 20 pounds I
go really is it still just 20. I'm doing
good
with the sad little face what do I have
to do I don't want to put you on
medicine what do I have to do oh my God
I want this doctor oh that's great I I
just got my one year physical thing and
I was like [__] she told me to take more
fiber because even though I'm a vegan I
have high cholesterol you may just have
high cholesterol exactly so she's like
you need to be taking more fiber and I
was like I didn't do that so did she
send you for a plaque test no that's my
dentist no no no no listen to me look at
this my mother was a nurse listen to me
yeah
um
uh I have high cholesterol I was about
220 222 somewhere in there
um
and my doctor is not he doesn't like
statins he goes if I don't have to I
don't want to you seem healthy go get a
a heart plaque test what does that mean
so they measure the plaque that's
building up in your arms
they put you in the MRI tube oh okay
it's non-invasive no it's not invasive
okay and because you can't invade and
three years ago zero
you did it zero he goes you have no
plaque so you got you got high
cholesterol it's not doing anything
that's the danger of high cholesterol is
it builds a plaque uh in the arteries
there's there's fat in your blood and if
it if it you know starts to congeal you
get blood fat in your blood there's no
fat in my blood no not in yours no no
I'm fine yeah here's the the shift that
a series of Netflix self documentaries
changed my life they were like don't
look at it like I can't eat these Foods
look at it I I can eat those Foods I
don't want to make it like a self-love
thing it's like it's like a blessing
thing like I can eat cake I've just done
it enough times to you ever notice you
eat some that you shouldn't eat and like
an hour or two later you just have Panic
if you notice this this well I almost
killed myself with a piece of uh
cheesecake in New York years ago I'm
gonna need to hear this story yeah let's
go to the mid-rolls when we come back
Jason Alexander in the deadly cheese
cake
pardon the interruption friends this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at dad grass I am seeing whenever I'm in
like a cool shop like a shop that sells
let's say shoes and jeans that I
absolutely love and need to have they
always have Dad grass and Mom grass at
the checkout and I'm so that's how I
first found it and I'm so glad that they
are a sponsor for this podcast dad grass
and Mom grass if you don't know are
incredible ways to relax to chill out
and to keep your head clear so chill out
all summer long with Dad grass because
it's too nice out to be couch locked
they'll mail you out while keeping your
head clear and ease away the stress of
the day what is it Dad grass is legal
organic hemp that relaxes your body and
Mellows your mind dad grass CBD products
are made with 100 organic hemp that's
easy to dose and the effects come on
smooth I can attest for that they it
looks you know it looks like it could be
a serious serious thing but is the
return of the Casual smoke I took a
couple puffs and I waited for some
freight train to hit me but I was
delighted to see like no this is like
some rocking chair stuff this is my
stress is melting away but I'm not going
into the rings of Saturn which I'm
really really happy to find something
like this they offer a variety of
products from their token smokable
pre-rolled joints as well as hemp flower
and variety of CBD tincture drops enjoy
the effects of CBD while keeping a clear
head all dad grass products are
federally legal federally legal for ages
18 and over and it ships right to your
door anywhere in the U.S so go to
dadgrass.com weird to check out their
products whether you're looking for a
new Buzz or a chill way to enjoy an old
favorite dad grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood right now dad grass is
offering our listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to dadgrass.com weird
that's dadgrass.com weird for twenty
percent off your first order get over
there that's dadgrath.com weird and it's
not written here but Mom grass is is
really great too I actually might prefer
mom crafts but they're both incredible
try both get a little of both get the
sampler also guys I know it's September
but it's hot as it's hot as it's hot as
the hinges of hell as we say like to say
in California but the temperatures
aren't the only thing that's Rising this
summer that's right this episode is
brought To Us by is sponsored by
bluetooth guys confidence can take you
far in life it can also help in the
bedroom especially when it comes time to
step up to the plate and that's where
blue chew comes in Bluetooth is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
anytime day or night so you can plan
ahead or be ready whenever and
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluechew.com consult with one
of their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package with blue
chew men everywhere are excited to see
the postman because when your package
has arrived your package has arrived
they always say first impressions are
important but what about Lasting
Impressions well it's time to get off
the couch and get back to work if your
tool needs an upgrade head to
bluetooth.com women say there's nothing
sexier than confidence and Bluetooth can
help give you that confidence where it
counts so if you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform Bluetooth can help and we've got
a special deal for weirdos try Bluetooth
free when you use promo code weird at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's
bluetooth.com promo code weird to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring the podcast all
right everybody back to the lovely chat
with the wonderful Jason Alexander
and we're back
yeah I had gone to see a piece of
theater in New York I thought you're
gonna say I went to see a piece of
cheesecake no no no I was in New York
and I went to see a a musical that was
previewing and it was it was just
everything about it made me angry it was
the only time I've ever left the theater
angry going how do you open your doors
and charge money and call this uh you
know and I'm and I'm with two friends
and we go to the now defunct Carnegie
Deli yeah sure which is notorious for
having portions that no human being
should ever eat and I order
two slices of Cheesecake because you're
on tilt from because I'm rage eating
yeah I'm rage eating yeah and I down
them with a glass of milk and I get back
to the hotel and I lay down and I can
hear my heart going oh
just trying to push this this sludge
through my system and I thought I am
going to die
yeah that's right no fun fact that's
exactly right it was and I and believe
me I got up I walked around I drank
water because I went this is I mean I
don't have a heart problem but I went
that that was Madness I just ate a
heartbeat yeah
you what happened you were okay I was
fine but yeah I went back to life thank
you another slice uh no I knew a guy who
he did a lot of this is this is not The
Joe Rogan Experience but here we are
um people realize The Joe Rogan
Experience is a thing and they just shut
this off wait I first that
um he smokes a lot of DMT do you know
what DMT is I do not
dimethyltryptamine you ever you ever
love how like Psychonauts like big
people into psychedelics know all the
chemicals yeah you're not talking to
that person but I've dabbled but
dimethyltryptamine is is the strongest
of the psychedelics it's like Buck
Rogers you smoke this very acrid harsh
smoke I'm not so I've never done that
and you go into another dimension that
is like overlaying on this Dimension um
everyone says the same thing it's more
real than this thing and all this sort
of stuff they also say that when we die
this is not proven uh there's no data
for this but people are like this might
be what's happening when we die because
DMT is in our bodies okay so maybe we
start to process it and we have these a
thing an experience but people are
really like or is it like a plant that
really makes you teleport because that
seems to be the experience okay but
because it's like
again I couldn't stress this enough I'm
not selling it to you again I haven't
done it but it's like
it's like
the most inexplicable crazy thing you
could do that's like dying it's like
you're gone you go and anything can
happen I've had people tell me they
smoke DMT and they're in a Coliseum like
ancient Rome kind of style but it's
filled with aliens real Star Trek stuff
loved you on Orville by the way there
they are and he's inside of a crab and
he's fighting another crab to the death
and I was like if I've ever done a
psychedelic it's usually been for a
spiritual reason and I'm like I don't
know what I would learn from being in a
crab duel so I'm out but
they say it might be what happens when
you die so a friend of mine uh he had an
accident they gave him some uh uh
opioids for the pain he may have taken
too many and he realized like you and
the cheesecake this is Shane Moss by the
way told the story on the podcast he
realized that he was dying because he
started having a DMT trip oh wow oh wow
he started crossing over and just like
you this is the best human beings can do
get up and walk around a little bit just
get up and try to watch little league
walk it off and it worked with you and
the cake and he he brought it that's
amazingly impressive isn't that wild
yeah he realized like if he yielded if
he just was like he would go because it
was pleasant it was kind of like oh wow
but then he was like oh I'm dying that's
how Shane talks and he got up and kind
of like cold water on his face came back
is wild [__] isn't that crazy yeah have
you ever done any psychedelics again not
clickbait I am the most boring man on
the planet I speak for myself and my my
wife when I tell you I've never been
drunk I've never been high
I am into it yeah I heard you say that
to Michael Rosenbaum that and that was
actually where I was going you you gone
on the couch
like an actor like somebody who's like
this is what's happening this is the
scene giant couch yeah I'll get on I'll
get on the couch meaning when I think of
like obviously it's a cliche but your
body is an instrument
you you mentioned that you don't drink
when you're doing Broadway eight shows a
week you can't do it people can I can
you I I'm absolutely the same way
especially a little bit older I couldn't
do what I used to do which is you know
drink after the shows and all that and
then do it all again the next day this
is a stand-up show but still stand up is
an hour long yeah yelling model I get it
see that that Mabus thing the the throat
steamer that that's that's right that's
your best friend yeah it's your best
friend you bet because you're like I
can't do it I'm doing warm-ups I'm going
to the doctor I can't hit the notes of
the monologue and I I heard you talking
about that but the reason I mentioned
I want to hear a little bit about your
acting your your philosophies of acting
the best advice you've ever gotten about
acting those those little mantras that
you keep with you but also the
physicality of it because when I'm like
oh maybe I should get more serious about
acting I always bristle that I'm like
and I'm not even proud of this it's not
like oh I don't like musicals because
they sing I don't like acting classes
because they're going to make me walk
like a polar bear or something you know
what I mean but there's this like
embarrassment threshold you have to get
over to get in your body and not be
embarrassed to
emote feel move like how many actors
would benefit from a little bit of this
right yeah tell me well again I guess
it's it's how you
so acting was what I what I mentioned
before I
always felt I never walked on the stage
I was this guy or that guy or this guy
so to me I can do things as George that
I I wouldn't want to do as Jason wow um
you know I I the thing that everybody
said to me you know please sign this
photo and I stop because I go I I could
be sending this to Children is the the
thing in Seinfeld where George was on
the shares and Kramer was doing the
photo shoot boxer shorts yeah
uh and they made a poster out of it
that's become fairly famous at this
point
um who books that
[Laughter]
it's something I can get who did that um
I mean that scene would have been hard
for Jason yeah Jason Goes come on I'm 20
pounds overweight and I'm balling them
I'm shorting them yeah
George is like
let's go yeah oh let's go so you just
went into him yeah it's just like yeah
and and the ideas of to me of
there are a lovely subset of people on
this planet whose body I think could be
considered Fine Art so the display of it
is kind of like a rapturous thing you go
well on a good day when God is doing yes
you know the best that's what we're
supposed to look like the rest of us
look like this and there's tons of us we
outnumbered them you know big time so
um so I've always thought bodies are
funny and my body's funny and as long
I'm much happier using my my body as a
tool for comedy than I am of romance you
know yeah you know oh certainly for me I
thought you meant words what about words
versus body
oh I'd much rather do words see I
thought I was going to be the great
classical actor of all time so I was
drawn to language yeah um you know not
physical stuff I had to learn to use
my body and surprisingly that's really
you talk about talk about acting a lot
of what I teach
is the physicality of intention
um
so intent you know in any given scene
hopefully you got two characters or more
and they want something different to
happen I'm trying to get you to do
something you're trying to get me to do
something it can be small it can be huge
the scene is about how do they work on
each other to to jockey for the outcome
so when you're finding that stuff you
actors can only play We yes we can I
always say this in class I go you know
we speak lines we say lines they don't
call us speakers they don't call us
orators
we portray feelings emotions but they
don't call us emoters they call us
actors why our job actions that's what
we bring that's what's not on the page
the actions wow so
actions are physical gestures and I find
most actors especially student actors
they leave their body behind they don't
use their body
and the reason they don't use it is
because they watch a lot of film where
actors seem to be stock-assed still yeah
and I say to them yes
many actors are many of them are
underwhelming remember they've got
scoring and camera shots and makeup and
light and all kinds of things helping to
create a moment in those and there's a
wisdom to that well Paul Bettany did
this podcast and I was like tell me the
greatest lesson you've learned about
acting and he said don't forget let the
camera do some of it that's very good
and by the way that's why I'm not I
think I'm a less effective filmic actor
than I am a stage actor because I forget
sometimes that the camera will fill in
some of that information but when I
teach I teach actors to use their bodies
very fully to show their partner and the
audience what their intention is because
if the other actor can go oh you're
trying to threaten me well then they get
to decide well how do I
do I feel threatened or do I laugh that
off or do I but if they can't read what
you're doing they just make something up
so the ball never gets passed back and
forth yeah so body becomes a very bad
having a panic attack
that's true but body body and use of
body becomes very important in the work
and then once your body understands what
you're playing what your action is yeah
you can actually then take the body out
of it and it will have informed
everything else in the performance think
about it then stop thinking about it
it's so interesting I I just today I was
talking to somebody and I realized I was
like
there's something I'm doing with my body
that is communicating to this guy that I
don't that I don't really respect him
and I corrected it I was like stop it
open up you know what I mean I was being
comedian to him I was like oh yeah and I
was like what the [__] you doing open up
and all that sort of stuff but I don't
yet have the
the cheat sheet meaning okay I'm going
to intimidate
maybe the Lurch for I don't know what
the do you have that mapped out yeah so
well first of all
when it's introduced to student actors
for the first time their brain freezes
it's a very actors don't like going into
their head they think that
the work comes from the emotions and it
can and and ultimately it needs to
but you'll hear actors go I'm just going
to feel it man I don't want to over prep
it I'm just going to feel it I'm just
going to feel it yeah I'm going to get
it off my partner I'm just gonna feel it
well if your partner comes in the same
way now you got two people going ah I'm
waiting for you and you're waiting for
me and buddy I don't know what to do I'm
just gonna react to you but everybody's
in hold waiting for this is why you
can't nobody's made a decision you can't
have two Michael rapaports
like the the wild cards I think he's
great that's why he came to mind yeah
but you also it's like Tom Petty uh is a
great front man but he wouldn't be a
great member of the choir you don't want
Tom Petty's voice in the choir right but
you can't necessarily have two wild
cards in a scene you need something to
work with for the other person you
actually can have well you can't have
two
um unchosen artists in a scene
somebody's gonna have to make choices if
you have two unchosen artists in the
scene
a third person is making choices either
the director or the camera or the son
somebody's making a choice interesting
somebody has to make a choice it's the
only way you can tell a story this is
how I'm gonna tell it yeah and all we're
doing is telling stories right so
somebody has to figure out
something they want to do to tell the
story
um actors don't like it they don't like
going into their head but when you want
but when you when you start thinking
about this stuff
there are two great books if you're
looking for them and they're almost
actor Bibles at this point one is called
actions for actors it's just a big old
thesaurus about you know uh to attack
can also mean to strangle to mutilate to
so that you know you can go well what's
the difference between
to attack which your body doesn't know
what to do with as opposed to to
strangle where you go oh now I know
exactly what it is yeah all the
interesting one I tell them I kind of
force my students to do their scenes or
monologues
only in their actions no words if you
can't tell your story without the words
then you haven't supplied your part of
the work this is like clown college I I
know that sounds absurd but I've been
scared of taking clown class my friends
have done it and they're like someone
like me I'd start talking that they'd
just be like stop talking I'd be like
but clown college is scary because it's
not just about intention it's about it's
the thing that makes Comedians and
comedic actors who are good at it they
have this extra little thing it's not
just about making choices something's
telling you how to make a funny Choice a
funny Choice yeah and so that's the
problem with clown college as you go am
I funny am I funny am I am I a funny
clown you know you're getting into my
ego and that's why I'm terrified of it
if somebody told me I wasn't funny I'd
be like I will now prove you wrong in
some absurd you go you'll go to anything
in order to get the laugh when for the
character the laugh is not the thing
they want right that's the Observer tell
me what I've had to um cry on camera and
somebody told me maybe my acting coach
Karen she was like the interesting thing
about crying is you have to cry it's
very crude you have to look like you
don't want to cry nobody wants to cry
only actors cry only actors go I'm
crying that's great
people in real life will do anything to
not be seen crying yes anything that's
the most humility anything but they're
like
there's like a perfect tear you're so
happy it happened uh there was a I had a
great moment about that um I was doing a
movie called love Valor compassion and a
really brilliant director a guy named
Joe mantello who does mostly theater
mostly in New York very little film it
was one of his I think maybe his only
film but
um and I had a big a big monologue a big
Aria man it's so emotional about the
tragedy that my lover is dying and he
has AIDS and nobody cares and I have
AIDS and I'm gonna die and nobody you
know and at the very end of the
monologue the guy I'm talking to I
turned to I go do you promise me that
you will be there when it's my turn that
your your face will be the last face
and I'm prepping this thing and I'm man
I wanna I Wanna Cry I want to rage I
want to
and Joe very smartly lets me do three
four takes and it's all working I'm
crying I'm you know it's great yeah
and he comes in around take five and he
goes we got it it's great we got it
I want to do one more I just want to do
something
um
you're not angry you're not scared
you're not I don't worry about that
stuff you just really want you don't
want to be alone when you die and you
know that he can't look at that stuff so
really make him promise just use the
whole monologue to get him to promise to
do that and I go Joe
come on that's like one you want me to
play one color one node for a two-page
model I guess try not to worry we got it
we got it this is just like a piece of
something just a piece yeah
so I go all right listen he's a great
director I'm going to trust him and I go
take a minute and then we do the scene
and I and I stop worrying about
everything else
and I go I'm going to make you promise
that you're going to be there I'm going
to say this whole thing to you so you
promised the actor I'm working with is a
wonderful actor named Steven spinella
and we get to the end of the monologue
and I'm emotional I've gone through some
stuff I'm not quite the Weeping thing
but for the first time
he's crying oh wow and we go cut and Joe
comes out from behind the camera like
you know cat that swallowed the canary
and goes
and I go
that's the take isn't it he goes oh yeah
oh yeah and he's absolutely right
because
it was all about Steven spinella it was
all about getting the thing my character
neither my character didn't need to be
seen crying my character didn't need to
be seen screaming he needed to feel
connected and not alone and not lost
yeah and that's and when when he started
working for that so I always say to my
students who have emotional scenes it's
a it's a rough way of saying it but I go
I don't really care what you feel
care what you make him feel
because in doing that I promise you
you will feel you can't plan action and
be devoid of the emotion that triggers
that action I really I feel like it goes
back to our thoughts about a good life
the service being outward not having a
panic attack there is a theme there's a
theme look at us but I think
all of this inwardness even we say this
on the Pod all the time but even look at
how shiny I am is a lonely Place yeah
because because you're defined by how
you feel about me I'm thinking about me
I'm trying to make you think about me
and and it's dangerous we love it in
this country uh you know not just this
country but you know the Tony Stark
thing be the guy with the iron suit no
one can hurt him and everyone wants to
be him and women want to be with him and
all that stuff but I'm like I actually
think it's the heroes are your mom and
and and I agree and David Lee Roth and
you teaching this stuff I'm meaning
there's a whole it doesn't all have to
be Mother Teresa or nothing but like
it's outwardness yeah yeah let's get
weird yeah
it wasn't that the Lenny Bruce routine
about
um
The Lone Ranger in The Lone Ranger
routine he used to do a thing about
The Lone Ranger doesn't stick around for
a thank you the whole crowd was angry
because what's with him Hi-Ho Silver and
a bullet and he's gone they can't stay
you can't get a thank you you can't give
him a thank you what kind of a person is
this you can't give a thank you that's
hilarious let's let's Lynch this basket
that is you know it's really great and
it's but that's kind of what
I mean I'd like to say this is how I
roll I I'm sure it's not but but there
is a joy to going you already thanked me
by participating yeah I had a great time
yeah doing this with you that was the
joy it doesn't need
it yeah you know it's like oh God this
is going to sound like such a pat on my
back and I don't mean it to but it was
one of the moments where I realized I
learned something and it was when my my
dear friend Julia Louis-Dreyfus was
getting her star on the Walk of Fame and
uh and she asked if I would come and be
part of it and I did and it was lovely
and I'm thrilled to be there and I I
came home and my boys were young
teenagers at the time and they said uh
Dad do you have one I went nope well
don't you want one
you know honestly I didn't quite think
about it I guess if someone handed it to
me I would
take it but I said but here's the crazy
thing guys I could I could take you up
there we can walk blocks
you won't know any of those names I mean
you know they were famous it's the Walk
of Fame you won't know those names yeah
and I said to them kill dingler yeah
right
um
and this is the moment that kind of
where they went I said you know honest
to God in this moment I can tell you
When I'm Gone
there are only two people in the world I
care if and how they remember me I'm
looking at both of them
I go I I don't I mean I would like to
have gone out with people going I'm glad
he was on the planet I got something
from that guy yeah
but when they go 20 years from now you
don't want them watching your movies and
I go
yeah God bless they watch them they want
I said I don't but any movie I've made
doesn't need to be here 20 years or so
goes to Alexander can come out right you
know pretty well yeah yeah exactly
because that holds up well
um
like man it's the cigarette case oh my
gosh and a toothy grip that's all we
need
no that's beautiful I also loved if you
were giving them that speech and we hear
in the background there's a track like
beep beep beep and they're unloading
like uh like a George Costanza bra
the only people I care about
my son and I my son Gabe is an actor and
he's wonderful and we did a short-lived
um uh series for free form called dinner
with Dad it was just these conversations
about life in the business from and he
played him and I played me and my
perspective his perspective and there's
one where we got into a conversation
about
um what name Dad are you going to have
on your Tombstone because my real name
is Jay Scott Greenspan it's not Jason
Alexander and I go uh
I don't know I guess it'd be like an AKA
you know he went you're going to put an
AK
it was like these are improv
conversations and we're like that's a
really good question do I care yeah if
somebody walks by that stone and goes oh
he's that guy how does that serve me
this is literally the answer to the
question when does it stop when's it so
I'm at a I've told the story before but
I want to tell it to you I'm at a ramdas
retreat I love ramdas wow you are
hardcore man
um yeah I was in a round us thing and
I was it was like doing late night it
was at the retreat and they asked me if
I wanted to go up on stage and and and
speak but as like a spiritual person I
was like oh not to talk differently but
to like do this wear this other hat
right and this is my biggest other
passion and ramdas is in the audience
and and uh and they're and no it wasn't
in Lamont that was the year I did so I
did it another time ramdas was not in
the audience but anyway here's my guy my
homeboy ramdas changed my life and I'm
watching the talk and I'm gonna be
brought on at the end and I'm sitting
there going like nobody's uh nobody's
nailing this like as a spiritual showman
I'm like that people are asking
questions I know what ramdas in 1978
would have said I could quote it
verbatim he's there he's like a father
figure to me I'm like I'm gonna quote it
like I'm gonna go up not only am I going
to go up on stage and take new questions
I'm going to go back and be like I also
feel like this could have been said this
could have been like a flourish like a
big you know like a medley like
just the choruses of every great musical
number ramdas has ever performed and of
course the fantasy is like play it out
now I do this I go what do you think is
going to happen he's going to be like
you're my chosen boy no one has
understood me but you I love you and
then and then the question after that is
like and then what you know what I mean
and then what then you'll feel okay I
know to ask those questions now to play
it out now right and to get honest about
what you want like what do you really
want and why do you want it but back
then I really just wanted to Razzle
Dazzle my my teacher yeah
and just like a late night show it's
getting later it's getting later it's
getting later the guy on stage goes we
we've run out of time and I'm like run
out of time this is being run like hate
Ashbury like it was sloppy it was slow
you can hear the ceiling fan that's not
good Showbiz if you can hear the ceiling
fan I'd get this thing popping so anyway
I'm bumped basically and I say to David
nichter and this Buddhist teacher who I
love
he's also like a mentor to me and I go
you know we're in a spiritual
environment we're on a retreat for
[__] sake but I'm just like I can be
honest with him like you with Mr Moss
right and I'm just like these
[__] like they asked me to be
here it's like disrespectful I'm sitting
here the whole time ramdas was there
like I'm having a good complaint in a
trusted place wouldn't do it publicly
but I'm doing it and he just goes Pete
when's it gonna be enough
and that's one of the greatest teachings
of my life
when's it going to be enough that's
right you with your son you're gonna do
it it's Jerry eating fries you're gonna
do an AKA
it belongs in the diner Gabe needs to
know that was premium content yeah AKA
like when's it gonna be enough but you
realized
it's enough
Walk of Fame what so a dog can poop on
your name listen it's a lovely thing I
know it's usually done generally it's
done there's a as a as a
tip of the cap yeah exactly and I go
okay I got a lot of those I you know
people have been very nice to me yeah
very very nice disproportionately
blessed that's right I don't know that I
need the thing in the sidewalk if
somebody wants to give it to me I'll
show up yes and I will make fun of it
because that's what we do in Jersey
that's right and then I'll go home and
when they go you gotta snug
yes I do
it's outside a porn shop on Hollywood
and Western
all right let's let's let's do some
weird questions I really want to get
some things you've never been asked uh
stuff here's one and feel free to dodge
it one time I was telling a sound guy
that I was nervous about EMF I I'm kind
of I don't know enough thing over there
and he said Jason Alexander is that way
is that something you've ever talked
about
no my wife so my wife you know because
we celebrate weird things and that's
yeah that's interesting yeah
my wife for a long time we had five
years of unexplainable infertility we
took every test and they went
are you [__] because we know are you
sure yeah
um and one of the things that she was
sure of is in our old New York apartment
a very thin New York City Apartment wall
separated the headboard of our bed and
the back of our refrigerator
and she was convinced that the EMF
radiation coming from the refrigerator
was somehow having an effect on
electromagnetic right
and so we she got the meters and yeah
sad Guru he's he's like you should face
to the I forget what he used I think it
might be the East but it's something
about the magnetic rotation sure and the
blood and the iron in your blood he's on
this tip all right keep going so my wife
got me into it and for a time there we
had someone wait did you move it and uh
we moved the bed and then baby no but
babies yes but not not because of that
um
we someone came out to our house when we
bought it and they went through with the
meters and said oh you got to move this
here and a pipe here and a thing here
and then it all came to ahead and come
back to Marty Short oh I'm sure must
have told great stories about this she
got concerned about the the microphones
the mic packs yeah so my wife made me uh
she got made for me cotton undershirts
that had a blocking material so that I
could put on the undershirt he's talking
about the back on the outside ordered
one of those hats there you go
so you you so you have a shirt to block
it I did I you know she has become lacks
about it and therefore I have become
lacks about it but we were for a while
there very serious about it it's
interesting we're back to the Mercury
pooling I'm not saying it's not
something worthy of anxiety but like
sometimes I get that way I'll become
obsessed and be kind of like how do I
get get this out of our lives
every young person I know
everyone under 30 that I know
their anxiety levels are off the charts
there's there's the level of anxiety and
depressive related Mental Health
that's either come out of the darkness
and we're just talking about it more or
it's more profound
these freaking phones that we wear on
our in our pockets next to our testicles
next to our kidneys
for a woman next to their breasts next
to their ovaries yeah I'm not sure that
we shouldn't be taking it more seriously
the people there were there were
scientists talking about that stuff with
much more and then it went away and then
it went away and either the research
went well it does something but we don't
know what we can't say that it's a bad
thing yeah but nobody's even looking as
far as I know nobody's looking at it
anymore yeah we took a trip uh exactly a
year ago my family and my
daughter-in-law's family we went rafting
for eight days in the Grand Canyon so no
cell signal no nothing wow man
you were back that was Bliss you were
back that was Bliss yeah there was there
was none of this stuff
there's that for sure and then there's
also and I'm not breaking any new ground
here but the book selfie that I'm
reading is all about why is everyone so
depressed why is everyone so then
because obviously self-obsession and
what does social media have to do about
that but when you're raised with it I'm
trying to work on this bit about how the
world is catching up to how I was as a
fundamentalist Christian where it's like
we'll send you to hell like if you make
a mistake we'll send you to hell and I
go this is the only joke in it which is
why I haven't done it I go the worst
part is that hell is real like meaning
your kids my kids are growing up in a
place where they see by the way this is
not sympathizing with with people who've
done terrible things I'm talking about
little mistakes bad bad things you
posted or whatever it is so please don't
think I'm apologizing for truly a
horrible bad behavior I'm just saying
you see what happens you make a mistake
oh and I was like welcome to my world
you're just you're just creating a
fundamentalist environment and also so
Church Lobby
khakis smile we play a part you play
Church Pete oh God bless you Jason as
soon as I get in my car I'm like [__]
phony you know to myself sure it's
private nobody's that big of a phony
that they would just start saying that
some of us were but I'm like that's
Instagram it's like in Naples or
whatever and it's like
I've been to Naples the first day jet
lagged you're not happy takes at my age
first three days of the vacation are
just acclimating to being on vacation
absolutely but the photos are like
crab-faced that's also a religious kind
of thing where it's like just look like
you're holy pretend like you're happy
pretend like you're holy and these
machines so say in the book selfie I'm
recommending it they talk about the kids
and the pressure where they even know
that they're full of [__] and they know
that they're full of [__] nobody's
actually happy you're just looking happy
but it doesn't matter knowing that it's
not real doesn't help we're still Human
animals we're still seeing images images
shape your reality yeah look to Young
and Freud for other examples of the they
have so many studies of like showing
someone an image and what it does to you
internally and now what you were doing
for eight days not just no EMF not just
no cell or in Internet no images
imagine that absolutely just reality
that's what I love about this podcast
that's why I hated my phone ring two
hours where this can just be the image
yeah just reality
sorry you got me on one of my topics
well just on on that time you know when
I when I knew the modern world was going
to take a turn for the for the worse and
I can't remember the day
but remember it has to be
12 years ago
watching something on CNN
a news story a news story yeah
cut back to Wolf Blitzer and he goes we
want to know what you think so tweet us
and I go you want to know what we think
what does it matter what I think it's a
news story it's it's a factual event
why why does my take on it and I went
are people gonna write in and tweet in
about this and that's when I went so
we're done Jay we're done this is the
highest compliment I can give an
observation it's ready for the stage
it's ready to go that's when I knew we
were done we're done it's so right
and as soon as we let in those voices
your brain you Jason Alexander J green
green Greenspan Greenspan for you think
Alan
Tim you give me a compliment you're an
accomplished actor all these things that
should mean a lot but I have to sit with
it but this guy on the street basically
driving by in a bus yells out the window
you look like you're wearing a travel
pillow
it's a burn I wrote for myself
and I I take you both as equal you know
there's no what is this guy by the way
beloved child of God I'm just saying
there's credentials there's the news
there's a doctor this guy was like you
should get a uh what the the plaque test
you know what I mean you got that from a
doctor that should matter more no new
ground here's here's some other other
things have you ever seen not just a
ghost or an or UFO but anything you
can't explain sure yeah hit it give me
one
so this is the one and only time that
I'm aware of that I wound up in the
National Enquirer and they actually
called to go we're just checking do you
want to comment on this and I had to go
ah it's kind of you got it right um I
was I was doing a movie I did Evelyn I
was doing that that Joe Mantella movie
and they we were shooting
um a little bit north of Montreal Canada
and the production put myself and my
family
in this lovely house
um
I can't believe I'm telling this story
in this house you know it's kind of a
bigger house than what we needed and at
some point I think they had said maybe
it had been an embassy or something like
that
nothing spooky about the house
um but we noticed you know some weird
things like my my wife is very sensitive
to smells so she doesn't wear cologne I
don't wear cologne we had a nanny I
almost said and refrigerators and then
the refrigerator
weird but there would be there would at
night there would be like a perfume
scent oh yeah that's good sorry uh at
night all of a sudden this has to be a
perfume scent and it would travel from
like one room to another we went oh
that's weird Okay and then classic also
at night we would think we were hearing
whispering in French
and we're going
and we're going what was that and we
couldn't and we couldn't source and we
thought maybe it's a radio frequency I
mean we're Montreal people speak French
yeah so maybe we're picking up a radio
frequency couldn't figure that out
The Nanny was coming down the stairs one
day and she's carrying my my younger son
was an infant at the time and she lunges
forward on the stair because she
protects the baby but she kind of bangs
up her arms and she goes I got pushed
[Music]
um by a French Canadian and then the way
the the way the house was set up my wife
and I were um in a bedroom my my younger
son an infant was in the room with us
and my older son was in the room next
door and then this nanny and this nanny
helper were staying at the other end of
the hallway down a significant hallway
in bedrooms at the other end
and the this one Nanny that was with us
we had she had been with us for three
years already great girl you know
nothing she's not a drinker not a
and we come down to breakfast one day
and she says to me I know the answer to
this but you wouldn't have had any
reason to me she says you wouldn't have
had any reason to be in our rooms last
night would you know absolutely not
because it was on fire there's no reason
I would be down in your rooms she went I
know that but we both and they were in
separate rooms they said we both felt
like there was a man in our room last
night and like okay so now that's all
the tea up too
yeah I have an early call one morning
for the movie like a 5 a.m pickup I come
out the bedroom door and the nanny
that's been with us is sitting on the
floor outside in her in her pajamas with
a blanket wrapped around her
hairless convenience she goes I'm not
staying in this house
and she swears that there was a male
presence in her room that she heard him
laugh
that it that there was a though the
windows were closed there was a enough
of a gust that it blew a lamp off the
bedside table and that there was this
Mist in this Mist swirled and kind of
came at her and she felt flushed and
abused and then the minute it stopped
the lamp came on on the floor and she
went she I said you were attacked by the
undead is that what happened she went I
don't know but I'm not staying in this
house and I had to call the production
and go thank you for this lovely house
we have to go to the Holiday Inn and we
need to go today because
we may have a we may have a ghosty thing
here and then somebody must have told
The Inquirer and they called and said is
is this true and I went well normally I
tell you guys to screw off but yeah
that's kind of what we think happens so
so there's that I mean that's that's
probably the thing yeah but I didn't you
know I didn't actually see it so I could
hear the voices and I could smell the
perfume and but everything else was
happening to other people and I was near
it but I haven't no I would love to
actually my I love Alien talk and UFO
talk oh really and I'm a big believer in
the possibility that was expressed in
Chariot of the Gods and things like that
about
that a lot of our mythologies and maybe
even some of our religions are all our
interpretations of you know aliens being
here
trying to do things with and for the
planet and for the species and speed up
agriculture yeah exactly and you know
and that was our so I love that stuff
but we've never seen anything I'd love
uh when we were in the Grand Canyon
um there you know I would watch the
night sky because it's true dark sky and
you just see things that are amazing
yeah and I would you know stare up
sometimes and you'd see Points of Light
you know moving in weird ways and you go
is that could that be a thing but you
know it's also who knows that but I'd
love to say I actually seen a bunch of
who knows that's what makes the night
sky so tricky is you're looking at a
bunch of who knows you're looking for
other who knows yeah you know what I
mean but you're like I already don't
understand this but is there something
else I don't understand moving through
the thing I'll tell you the great thing
though if you do if this is my big my
big push for go do this trip it's so
clear and it's so brilliant that you can
lay there and you see satellites go by
we saw the the space station go by and
you could see it plain as there you go
oh sure that's that ship can you hear me
[Laughter]
you know Houston we just had a spotting
of him
wow no that I would love to do that what
the right age for my
daughter is well that's you know I we
don't have to talk about that but moving
where we moved uh up north of the city
seeing the moon every day right oh I
didn't know I needed that I tell you
turns out I need the moon any psychics I
have to imagine it'd be fun for you to
call a psychic and they tell you
something
[Music]
you are so familiar to me and not the
characters
I'm like I know this guy so we've we had
um this is the most profound one so like
I said my wife and I had five years of
unexplainable infertility
um both my boys are in vitro
um
we had moved to LA we had done some
reproductive stuff we had tried a cycle
or two in New York and nothing happened
and we had come out to L.A and we just
we weren't we didn't know what we were
going to do and
we heard of a couple doctors and we so
we met a couple of fertility doctors and
there's one guy that we really liked a
lot
um
and then we had reason to go back to New
York before we made any decision and my
mother-in-law is the one who loves the
psychics she's really into the psychics
she said you have to go see Frank
Andrews Frank Andrews has passed away
since then but Frank Andrews was a man I
don't think he was five feet tall he was
like Truman Capote he was just having
this little Southern kind of you know
affect thing and he had a brownstone
down in the in the village and he raised
Papillon dogs so they had these little
Papillon dogs running great on a salad
and his thing was um it just sounded
like a type of pepper sorry
yeah extra Christmas
um
and he says we come in and he doesn't
know because Seinfeld wasn't a thing yet
and he didn't have and even if he knew
who I was we weren't necessarily there
for anything other than oh go see a
psychic what a lark you know not knowing
what he's going to talk about
and we get into his room and he goes
this is the strangest thing because I
normally I I do palms and I do tarot and
I don't I'm not a medium
he goes you know I I invest in things
like I look at somebody's hand and see
if there's anything you know he said but
it's like I'm hearing a voice and I just
have to tell you what I'm hearing maybe
it'll mean something to you
you've been working on a project for a
while and it hasn't gone well and you've
just taken some meetings and you've met
someone named Peter or Paul I get those
confused and I think it may be a last
name like Peterson or Peterman or
something like that and the voice is
saying if you do the project with them
it'll be successful the guy that we had
liked was a guy named Dr Richard Paulson
and we went that's really weird and we
came back and we signed up with Dr
Richard Paulsen and he made my sons when
nobody else could and that was a thing
where we went well what is that all
about where did that come from
um so yeah I mean once or twice there's
been
and I listen I'm in the magic world I
know how yeah fake psychics do a lot of
their stuff but that was one of those
things where there was more for him to
lose than gain and it wasn't like this
the letter g mean anything to you it
wasn't bad [__] it was like I'm hearing
Peter or Paul and I think it's like a
last name like Peterson or Paul I don't
even normally do this right it has all
the earmarks of authenticity very cool
yeah wow yeah and then he went and buy
your mother-in-law a house fire
no he was he was very cool
and uh we're sort of running close to
the time here not we don't I just want
to be respectful of your time what you
don't add it oh for God's sake I'm here
we don't know oh for God's sake there's
no attitude
um any framework for the meaning of life
I know that's a heavy question the
meaning of life here with you meaning
any any deity any structure when you die
do you think it's over you just told me
a story about I mean it's so easy to
think that that was a soul
uh brokering the deal for the souls of
your son sure from a pre-birth place
yeah of course I don't think any of this
is literally true I think it's all
happening kind of all at once basically
um that's one of the fun things that
Rupert Spira taught me it's like time is
how eternity constricted into the shape
of a human perceives eternity as time
but it's really all just
okay you know what I mean I said I've
never been high but I'm about to get
so what I'm saying is it doesn't need to
be like how we tell stories there's a
pre-birth area over here and there's
your boys and they're like well let's
tell them to go to that doctor so
they're born but uh it makes me wonder
do you have any story that you like or a
framework that you like for the meaning
of this I will tell you two uh two
anecdotes that sort of sum up where I am
in my questioning of what is it all out
there
when my first son was born he had some
sort of bronchial infection he spent his
first 10 days in the Intensive Care Unit
and he got a little better before he it
got a little worse before he got better
and
when we didn't know what was going to
happen I found myself in the chapel
and I'm not a religious person so I will
start with that and talking to God and
saying
um
this might be a twofer
I don't know if I can survive
getting choked up I don't know if I
would survive have you taken please
don't do this
these are rock he's not been sick a day
in his life he's great
but when I tell that story I go you know
I've never had a suicidal thought I'm
nobody's hero
I had just met this man
why would I do that for a stranger
I mean yes there's biology yes there's
chemistry I get it we're animals and in
nature
parents protect their babies but they
don't throw themselves off a cliff for
their names
what was that about was this a soul that
I had known in some way shape or form
before because he didn't feel like a
stranger to me and that his his the loss
of him would be too costly so that's one
story and then that's beautiful I feel
like we have to unpack that a little bit
oh really okay that might be worse well
it's just beautiful first of all it's so
beautiful it's silly to do a bit the the
chapel in hospitals
yeah cedarsana serious serious Place
yeah and to throw out that Earnest of a
prayer when you're not even a Praying
person yeah that's not my relationship
and when you said it too fur you meant
like I might go I I I'm I don't know if
I'll survive it right I I it may be more
than I can bear yeah we worked so hard
to get this child well you were also
transformed by love you saw a good
definition for love is seeing yourself
in the other recognizing there's as Dr
uh Dr uh father Greg taught me there's
no sunlight between us we're so close
there's no sunlight between us yeah but
that's true of of us but you wrecked
sometimes the kids are the ones that
unlock the place in us where we always
were in love and if there is
truth to the connection of Are We soul
mates
um
I mean I I just understand that there
was a some book I had read sometimes
said that soul mates are literally
fragments of one giant Soul that
recognize each other oh we're part of
the that's you I'm Reckoning it yeah but
the but what I would tell my kids
when they were little about you know
death and dying when that would come up
and I'd say well
because they go I made them you know
we're I grew up Jewish
um I'm not a practicing Jew I mean
culturally you can't wipe it off man nor
would I choose to yeah
but we're not religious Jews
um but we made my sons get Apartments
because I went there were people that
will kill you because you're a Jew you
might as well know what you're dying for
so my god
um and I also said you know it's your
choice I chose it's not the way I roll
but you you should hear about it we're
chosen YouTube yeah right choose make a
choice you're the chosen people
um actress act chosen shoes so they
would ask about death and dying and I go
well here's here's what I'll tell you
I don't know is there a god I don't know
I said I've watched two people take
their last breath
the moment before that last breath they
are there
and the moment after that when my father
died I literally went
as if I could
I mean there's something about the
exhalation of that breath where I went
whoa and it's kind of tracked it with my
eyes and you know he's hooked up to a
thing that's reading the electrical
impulses of his body they're there he's
generating power yeah
takes a breath
gone and science tells us you cannot
create or destroy energy you can only
change it
so I look at that and I go well what did
that energy become um where did it go is
it attracted to like energy does it does
it become air molecules does it become
water whatever it is I don't so to me I
having seen that I tend to feel like
whatever that is has Soul connection on
it I don't know if it's sentient I don't
know if it has any trace of our
personalities or our histories or our
memories or our growth or anything I
just think
it's a living energy and something
happens to it so then I go and I think
about God another way to put it would be
nothing happens to it or or nothing that
happens
it's very interesting yes yes or no but
is it is it isn't it
um
tell me yeah
so I have trouble believing
I'll go this way Big Bang is what's
created the universe Big Bang what was
there before the Big Bang what was the
moment what made the Big Bang there was
nothing then there was a big bang
something made a big bang
I have trouble getting away from the
notion of a creator
a creator
I don't know that it's sentient I don't
know that it's living in the way we
think of living I don't think of it as
the biblical God that I have to talk to
and ask for presence and make promises I
don't think that's our relationship I
think the universe was created I think
it was created for purpose and I think
we are part of the exploration of that
purpose
and that our lives if nothing else
return
information
[Music]
to that source and that eventually
time space physical time space
will be done at some point the universe
will be done
but I don't think the Creator
comes from this time space reality I
think the Creator lives outside of that
reality and so there are other realities
there are other what do you want to call
it Dimensions there are other there are
other some things maybe when we go
were called back to that I don't know
um but I tried to think about
you create something in the hopes that
it will have
reason and it will be a good thing
you don't knowingly create bad things
very rare
[Music]
so I tend even though I'm not a
religious person
people say to me well how do you know
right from wrong how do you know good
from bad if something is in the service
of creation
that does not destroy that does not
impede that does not block that does not
separate that does not divide
I tend to think it's in the service of
creation and therefore must be in the
service of the creator
and everything that is not that
you can call it evil I don't know that
it's evil but it's just not in the
service of its intended purpose it's not
in the flow it's not in harmony it's not
in the flow yeah and that's that's kind
of where my spirituality lies and it's
it's
I don't know so when I talk to somebody
like Bill Maher who goes you don't
really believe that [__] I go yeah
I'm too scared to not believe it
I'd like to believe that
it doesn't have to be me
but I'd like to believe that there's a
reason me existed other than to fill up
space for a period of time yeah there
must be something more to it than that
it doesn't have to be me it can be just
you know we wasted you we put this in
your flesh and blood and now we're going
to take it back and make it a mortar
water molecule that's great something
will swim in it something will drink it
something they'll do something with it
great but it's still purposed you know
yeah you might not have a star on the
Hollywood Walk of man but you might
become a star right we are Stardust do
you um I don't know do you want to do
another take so you can give a good
answer
by the way the podcast that I'm
launching is not like this at all you're
going to be on it eventually I'd love to
it is my friend Peter and I understand
my joke I do I I I guess as if written
please if you have to explain jokes okay
good but yeah my friend Peter Tilden and
I are launching one on iHeart in
November and it's called really no
really and you will almost surely be on
it whether you're on it or not because
it almost always begins with a
comedian's joke observation there we go
yeah what is that and then it becomes
something big picture and we talk to
Fascinating People that wow that we make
fun of throughout the whole thing and I
can't but it's fun really no really edit
that out but I can't wait yeah
Neil deGrasse Tyson had a very similar
answer to you too he's like I observe a
universe that is constantly churning
itself and he's like when I die I
feasted on the floor and the Fauna of
this planet and to return to it and be
feasted on he's like it's a great
privilege to re-enter the cycle and all
that that's interesting that that
interests me a little less yeah I don't
love being a smorgasbord but other than
necessarily want to be fun yeah you want
to be fun yeah sorry it's just so hard
not to be why would you want to be fauna
gotta go Flora Flora before fauna never
been sicker you do a pretty good
Seinfeld by the way thank you very much
yeah okay would you and how I'm not even
going to ask you uh to do anything I
want you to know because I wonder I
would wager a lot of money that you've
never gotten this of all the Seinfeld
things uh this okay you think there's a
very good chance you've heard it before
no I think there's or I've forgotten it
that's okay no I'm not putting you on
the spot okay George your character says
uh I don't even remember when it wasn't
neither do you it's fine but you say
you're serious aren't you and you go
you're serious aren't you for some
reason you really say like aren't you
almost every morning Valerie and I pour
some cereal get some more and she just
and say to our daughter your cereal
orange juice and it's just
it's just a joy to tell you that well
thank you it's one of the things you're
serious aren't you and you made it funny
I think you're in the the Yankees office
and they're telling you to leave or
something
it doesn't matter but it's one of those
George moments you go what maybe she
showed up even after you were fired and
they're like get out of here and you're
like oh that wasn't at the Yankees but
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah you know that's
a true story Larry David SNL yeah just
act like you didn't do it yeah Kenny
Kramer I came up with that well let his
name never be spoken in his bus tour of
design oh my God I'm just kidding oh my
God I think about it all the time
because I read scripts and and I love
picking names from my youth not that I I
don't really know the Kenny Kramer story
but I'm just sort of like you got to be
careful
with the names that you've had yeah it's
very true but it couldn't be Kessler
it couldn't have been started as
gasoline I know he had a dog too so let
me ask you I'm going to ask you a
question oh okay so the last series you
did you did a season and it went away
how do you so what's the feeling about
that
well thank you for asking it took I just
called the creator of the show Mark
gross two three nights ago and we both
had the same experience which was maybe
it's a masculine thing I think all of us
do this as a self-preservation
when it got canceled I'm just forward
momentum I'm just like okay I've had
I've had the privilege of having several
shows be canceled
it's all part of it right it's like Mad
Men the day you sign a client is the day
start losing them it's all part of it
means you're in show business so I have
this like wonderful spin doctor
technique of like what a privilege that
we got to do it this is true we didn't
waste a day we had fun every day
and I've been on other sets didn't have
the same Vibe we had fun like you said
about Seinfeld you're hanging out
watching other people's scenes I'm
pitching jokes to other people not just
my own when it was okay yeah you'd be
like okay
beautiful we did not waste it then it
get canceled and I spin and then meaning
make it positive just keep moving I have
other projects other things I want to do
but it's all good
I even said on the podcast on this
podcast I was like there's a there's a
fuel to a no and that is true you'll
work harder you'll write more you do
these things and I actually think the
the Big Wigs the Bezos is the the
zuckerbergs or whatever that don't get a
lot of no's I bet they manufacture no's
because they know there's a certain kind
of charge you can only get from someone
telling you no and I I really was
spinning out and then I had to go like
what a [__] bummer like I had to own
it I had to go like that sucked I didn't
know Show Business could be so simple
and what I mean simple I mean go to the
same place crashing we were driving a
Long Island you know in a van a two-hour
drive and shoot two scenes that was your
day right this was the whole day little
play [__] around getting to know
everybody so I really had to
the real courage or the real strength
wasn't suppressing that it was that it
was owning that it was sad and I called
Mark and I was like are you ready to
talk about and he was like I was doing
what you were doing I wasn't being
honest about how sad it was because we
were a special cast we loved each other
I that sounds like Shoney phony phony
Shoney Boney Like Show Business nonsense
yeah like love you babe it wasn't like
that well sometimes real fast and that's
when we were like we're not going to
come back our way because you have to
like he almost like you want those shows
that everyone hates each other yeah yeah
but but that's what it was like it's
hard I've I've had three that have
crashed and burned after Seinfeld yeah
it's it's hard yeah you know yeah it's
it doesn't get easier then no because
you you
know with Seinfeld it was actually
easier because it wasn't my show so I
you know
I'm not running the thing I'm I'm a cog
in the wheel that's all but when you're
when you're you know closer to the hub
of the wheel and it doesn't work you
start to go
do I not no good from bad am I not funny
am I right right am I not supposed to oh
you know what it maybe is maybe I
shouldn't be number one on the call
sheet that should be number three on the
call you start doing all that stuff yeah
um
and then you know you go through the
through the period of well they are
[__] you go through that period
um this is morning yeah some mornings
yeah yeah denial you bet maybe they'll
maybe they'll put it on Paramount plus
oh yeah they're gonna move us see that's
the thing from the theater yeah my
Broadway debut was was a what is now a
very famous uh Stephen Sondheim
fail
and um as they were putting up the
closing notice they actually said
there's a very good chance we're going
to move to an Off-Broadway theater and I
went
why why would someone take us from
Broadway where we flopped and go you
know where it'll work smaller theater
let's put this um damaged heart in a
healthy body yeah basically I I never
believed that that's just something that
they said maybe we'll go somewhere else
but it's like I don't think so guys I
don't think this is well you are a
supremely I'm gonna be nice to you now
you're a supremely talented man oh thank
you you have made me and my family laugh
so much with such smart stuff
you're never going to not find places to
to do that well it's just you know I
hope that there are always places that
you go I I'm happy to be doing it here
and doing it this way and isn't it funny
I I really appreciate that and and like
the letter you wrote Stephen Sondheim
remember yeah I do listen to inside of
you for that story because Mike what a
great guy to put us in touch with a
match really he's you know and I only
know him really we have yet to we had
one lunch together
but you you do click with him pretty
fast he's a really but the fact that he
put us in time there's some people that
are just like
I'm not gonna yeah but he knew that the
gift is giving it away and putting us in
touch but I had that moment like son I'm
when you wrote him that letter and I
never had it I was a little embarrassed
Valerie my wife always says it's not
just the feeling it's the shame that you
have the feeling so I was having the
feeling which is an actor cliche which I
was like am I not done but like is it
going to be 10 years of wilderness or
something that's never happened to me
I've Tarzan swung
from for four things basically four
great things I was like could this be it
and I'm already doing stuff but like
you're wondering what the so what I'm
saying is thank you that was a long and
fumbling way to say thank you and from
you so much more what uh I appreciate it
and to you as well I I have that creator
of mine I'm sitting here going like you
know what your problem is not your
problem I'm like maybe Jason is a great
dramatic actor obviously you are it's
like is there like a Breaking Bad and
then I'm like you're so Charming this
smile what do you do with that smile the
smile you greeted me with I was like
whatever it is and I know you're
directing and I know you're killing it
and you're fulfilled and you're teaching
and it's wonderful so I'm not trying to
fix a problem but as a show writer red
Creator I'm like what is it oh I don't
want to go back in a second if it was
the you know it's the it's got to be but
it has to be something that addresses
that smile it can't just be let's have
him be yeah the math Guy It's gotta be
the smile too
yeah it's like that's the thing is like
people do call me to be an actor
of course I said Oregon oh yeah but I
kind of
didn't I do that yeah um and and who am
I doing it with because that doesn't
sound like yeah it's not that they're
good bad or experienced or otherwise it
just it sounds like they're gonna
they're gonna have a very I love when i
i people approach me with something and
they go we just want you to do you and I
go you don't know who I am yeah I'm in
there I'm just figuring out this
character that I played is the one that
you think is me right you know
um because I've even played have you
done this where you play yourself and
stuff sure and I go and I will show up
and go which which me are you speaking
of even that isn't me yeah yeah because
I go that's even stand at me isn't me
right you can't you think I mean it's
the closest
one that you've created for yourself
it's exaggerated yeah I'm not am I
yelling at you right now you know what I
mean like Sage be very very different
from real people so you know I keep and
I've got a couple of ideas I got one
idea that I think is so good but it
needs a really smart all right but it's
uh it's when we're not sharing I'll tell
you what oh please tell me about it
there's nothing
when we talk about knowing ourselves Val
helps me with that she's like you love
writing things I love getting I don't
know if it's an add I don't know if I
even have 80d but I love getting tunnel
vision somebody just said to me they
were like you should write something for
you and Maya because Maya Rudolph did
this podcast and I just took two days I
haven't even told her about it but I was
like okay it's this it's based on this
couple that I know like love it I get
caught in that Timeless space well that
is a gift to be able to to get an
inspiration like that and execute it
that that so you're saying like you can
memorize a monologue real fast yeah and
act and create a character all that
stuff uh sorry to make this about me but
that that is something
my Savant ability is that what you said
yeah is that your thing my survivability
put it on paper quickly if you say like
I would love I I don't know I I actually
believe I could do it as well uh
certainly in time uh Mike White wrote
White Lotus in like I think he wrote in
a couple weeks and she's got like 50 I
mean I just knew it I mean just did it
there's there's those of us that like
that like
the the stories in my life I get notes
on a pilot they're like you should
completely change it two days later send
it finished you know what I mean I like
those snowed in a log cabin
like you don't even Name the characters
you just name them Bill Jam because you
don't want to waste time going it's a
waste of time by time if I taught a
class on writing I'd go stop doing this
Jim
PowerPoint enters the room just name
them people you went to high school with
and keep moving because that's not it
doesn't matter that you have well maybe
you do that is uh that's a superpower
that is a superpower because that's
where most I I think I can write yeah
but to power through the
and then what happens well if they do
that then that's the end of that but bad
and I talk myself out of it yeah nothing
pleases me more if somebody outlines
something with me I did something with
the the show I'm talking about was with
Adam McKay he he outlined that and then
when I handed in and it's different from
the outline because I went into like a
shamanic Fugue state where I was like
it's not that and you he doesn't say why
is it different he just goes it works
you're like
it's one of the great jobs it's one of
the great Joys I didn't mean to make it
about me right here no I that's I asked
the question you know that's fantastic
well you got one more because we ask
everybody this question okay I've
enjoyed this I sort of feel like I'm in
like with a high school friend i i i i
before I even said that I made sure I
extricated it from the familiarity sure
of watching you so much
this I love it feeling it
um can you tell me the time a time in
your life where you laughed so hard you
had tears rolling down your cheeks I
always give this little caveat doesn't
have to be a good story in fact I'll
settle for how old you are who you're
with hear the prompts maybe someone
farted maybe someone fell down I know
you weren't stoned but
I have to think rehearsing
I have to think
flubbing a line
um it's there's one moment that's coming
to mind that's actually on television
you can see it it's on a Seinfeld
episode it's just carefully hidden what
it's in the Seinfeld episode called the
parking garage where we can't find our
car in a multi-story parking garage yes
it was the first time we shot the
Seinfeld show without a live audience
where we actually did it like a movie
you know we came in and we shot for four
days you know and they were long days
because we did it on our Sound Stage in
the way that we would go from floor to
floor in the parking garage I'd change
it change the cars around Chainsaw the
signage and then there were mirrors on
the perimeter so that it looked like it
kept going and going and going it was
beautifully done
but we're Punchy you know and we're
we're really but and it's it's day four
and it's the last night and we are
we're in Golden time I mean we we're
we're not getting it done
and it's the last scene it's we finally
found the car and now all that has to
happen is Kramer has to get he's been
carrying an air conditioner around while
looking for he's got to get the air
conditioner in the car and Elaine's got
the bag with the two goldfish I've
missed the movie that I'm supposed to go
with this wonderful woman that I can't
remember what Jerry was trying to get to
but
and all that is left to do is a couple
lines put the box in the car get in the
car drive off that's it and we are
stupid we're laughing at nothing
laughing at nothing Jerry said Julia had
a line what about the little fishes you
know or something like that and he said
do it in the cutest voice you can do it
in we'll have a cute contest and so
she's going
duties you know now we're all trying to
top her and we're just laughing at
nothing and they're going action and we
can't get a shot in and it's two o'clock
in the morning you know and
and our director hits the wall and he
goes God damn it
for the goddamn and this is it I don't
care what happened
and we're like you know little children
now
it was uh Tom sharonis it never raises
his voice yeah
um
so we're like okay we're in trouble now
Jerry and I basically have our back to
the main camera but Michael is in dead
profile and Julia is completely exposed
and Michael's got this box with a real
air conditioner in it because he want
you know Mr method he wanted to carry
around a real air conditioner for that
oh my God if you tried to carefully put
this box into the trunk of this car you
have about a three quarter of an inch
Dead Zone around it it's just barely
going to fit in this trunk but if you do
it you can get it in
Michael decides after this chastisement
that he's going to do a Kramer he's
going to have it come off his shoulder
and he's gonna he's gonna get it in the
trunk that way
action and he goes yeah yeah and he does
a thing with his body well of course the
the lip of the trunk stops the Box dead
and Michael's face keeps going and he
smashes his face into the corner of this
box and he's now split his lip and he's
bleeding from the lip
and there's nothing funnier on the
planet
I mean Jerry and I you can kind of see
our shoulders are going we're trying to
not do anything that's going to ruin
this shot
Julia is exposed right and she's
she
is so ready to laugh but she's
containing it and to the point where she
starts to cry because she's she's
fighting so hard to contain it that the
tears are rolling down her eyes
Michael who never breaks character looks
at her sees that she's in trouble
and ad-libs
it's not funny Elaine
I hurt myself which is
[__] hysterical we are I mean I I was
so close to having appendicitis from
trying to not let the sound of this
tears rolling down my face but I'm the
camera can't see me we get in this car
Jerry and I are in the back Julia's in
the passenger seat Michael's it's
Michael's car and we are supposed to
start this car and drive off he turns
that key and the [__] thing won't
turn over
that car is rocking Jerry and I are
pounding each other in the back seat
screaming
crying laughing it is be I mean I don't
I don't remember when I've laughed that
hard
and and sharonis was good to his word my
Michael Michael tries to turn the car
over three times steps out of the car
looks off in the distance steps back in
tries it again
cut and that's how the episode ends we
never shot another one after that but
that was
I mean that was that was one of those
experiences where you know I hold that
and I go God I love those three people
because to have that moment
yeah and it's just that we're the only
ones who know it we know what that was
you know and how
how hard I mean you've been there where
you're not supposed to be laughing you
don't want to ruin the thing and you
just it was so delicious so delicious
I mean best answer of all time I think
uh but also I just I really love that
Michael said it's not funny Elaine I
hurt myself right it's not funny in that
moment to be like you should see the
other guy or some something dumb to
really be like it's not funny Elaine
like to use the name I heard myself use
the funniest thing you could say
absolutely as I always say you could
have taken a four hour break what's the
best line it's not funny Elaine I heard
I hurt myself
to a woman who is weeping she's laughing
so hard yes
it's not funny Elaine I hurt myself
isn't in the episode I don't think no
they cut that I cut that I mean and they
managed because they you know they were
rolling three or four cameras they
managed to cut around enough that you
don't quite see the tears on Julia's
face but there is a shot of the car
rocking where you can see Jerry and me
in the back seat smacking each other
because we're just I can't that was
again the Mike Michael uh Rosenbaum
podcast you tell the story about the
writing the hole in one all the guys he
was angry that day
the way that that manufactured this
perfect ending and the car not starting
is also a perfect ending perfect it was
discovered on the day absolutely you
watched and you're like those are the
only way those episodes could have ended
absolutely but that's that sort of
kismet and fun and joy and flow that you
need and what a fun and beautiful answer
the best yeah yeah yeah well tell me the
idea I have a
I have a free couple hours I'm just
kidding somebody you'll love the idea if
it ever comes to television you'll love
the idea but it's um it's a fun idea
I'll tell you in a minute all right well
uh we have the guest at the end of the
first of all thank you so much what a
joy thank you a pleasure would you uh
say keep it crispy it's how we end the
guest says the catchphrase uh it doesn't
mean anything bad okay keep it crispy
it's how we end that's it
well melon's never done that I mean it I
really mean it you're serious orange
juice thank you so much Jay thank you
[Music]